good morning everyone now call the
committee to order
representative martin you're recognized
to lead us in the pledge of allegiance
the flag of the united states of america
to the republic which stands for one
nation
indivisible with liberty justice for all
the committee now
calls we have to open the hearing
at this time we'll now open the public
hearing on senate bill 306 relative to
the penalties for various motive motor
vehicle
violations the committee now calls
senator reagan
good morning
criminal justice and public safety i'm
senator john reagan from senate district
and i bring to you today senate bill
306.
which is a bill that passed
in a previous session of the senate and
then got lost in the
disaster that was coveted
so
here's your chance
against the
penalties for distracted drivers who
are violating the
no electronics
and
today is
a victim
of a distracted driver
who has
and it's looking like decades
of pain and suffering
because of a distracted driver
so
i will let
lisa beaudoin
explain
the
tragedy that struck her life from the
distracted driver and was the driving
force
toward creating this legislation
representative bert
thank you um
mr chairman
how do we
i guess how do we enforce this
when
the police aren't enforcing it
you know because you know i see them
texting all the time you know i don't
know if that's what this is about but
you know i
i'm sitting at the red light and there
they are texting away just like the
other cars in front of them and
everywhere else so how do we enforce
this
if they're not enforcing it and they're
doing it themselves
i think the the greatest impetus to this
is the penalty
that happens if you're charged
and apparently the
current penalty is not enough to make
people stop doing that
so that's the hope with the enhanced
penalty
all right thank you
representative bourdain
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um
this is an uh
uh sentence c
offensive will constitute a uh class a
misdemeanor will be charged to a class b
felony can you exam give me examples of
validations that would make a
class a misdemeanor
i'm not an attorney and
not a law enforcement officer so i can't
help you with that
thank you very much
representative manju puti
thank you mr chair thank you senator for
taking my question wasn't this um
bill
not
last term but two terms ago that was
passed and didn't we have a lot of uh
data in terms of the crash and fatal
crashes in state
that had um
texting
just before the car crashed and
and if i recall i was
on this committee at that time
and many teenagers including my daughter
came up and said this is wonderful to
have so that
it can save a lot of lives
uh wasn't this the same bill that was
yes thank you
representative harry gathering thank you
mr chair and thank you senator for
taking my question it's kind of on the
line of what um
the representative from nashua stated um
was there data on this how often this is
happening and what have you
i don't recall it from there was at the
time i'm not sure if anyone has that
yes we have that for you today okay
thank you
seeing no hands raised i want to thank
the senator for his testimony
the committee now calls lisa bowden
good morning
chairman abbas and honorable members of
this committee
my name is lisa beaudoin thank you for
the opportunity to share my story
supporting sb 306.
it is critically important to me that
some greater public policy good comes
out of the challenges i and my family
experienced
due to a law-breaking distracted driver
i am a devoted hard-working executive
director of a small non-profit and the
proud mum of two young men
forest who lives here in concord and my
younger son rowan who is a senior
at wesleyan university
on december 19 2018 i was driving home
from a meeting on route 101 in amherst
when a driver took his eyes from the
road distracted by his phone and cleared
two and a half lanes of traffic to crash
head-on into my toyota prius
and nearly killed me
the captain of the amherst police
department told me he thought the
coroner's truck had already left when he
arrived
that's how bad the scene was
in august 2019
delivering an in-person thank you to the
amherst first responders who saved my
life and share with them a happy ending
i learned that a veteran of 31 years in
first response
literally saved my life by sticking his
two fingers into my left femoral bleed
while the jaws of life
freed me so that i could then be med
flighted to umass memorial medical
center in worcester
my sons an extended family sat
terrorized for two days wondering if i
would live or die
neither doctors nor medication could
control the excruciating pain i was
feeling
for three full days
over the course of the first eight days
i underwent five surgeries to repair
multiple fractures across my body
i had three broken limbs
broken femurs in both of my legs one
femur was blown into 20 pieces the other
was a compound fracture which broke
clear through my leg
both knees were broken broken ribs
clavicle scapula and a broken left ulna
and these are among the many injuries
that i am still recovering from
at one time five metal plates a titanium
rod and dozens of pins and screws held
my body together
a device called an external fixator
which is pictured here
had four pins drilled through the
outside of my skin and through my leg
bones which then immobilized my leg for
four months
those five inch pins were unscrewed
while i sat awake in my surgeon's office
the pain was reminiscent of a medieval
torture scene
for six months i completed two to three
hours of physical therapy a day
over three years later i'm down to one
hour a day
because of my injuries at the time for
four months i needed round-the-clock
care for bathing dressing eating
drinking and the removal of excrement
from a bedside commode
i am very lucky very lucky that my
family friends and neighbors pulled
together to help me or i'd have been
stuck in a rehab facility extending to
my significant recovery costs
to let my surgically fused bones set
both legs were non-weight-bearing until
the end of march
i it wasn't until june when i was
cleared to begin to re-learn to walk on
both legs
needless to say i am lucky to be alive
after the reckless and careless conduct
and decisions of a distracted driver who
hit me
to date i have had 10 surgeries and have
had
to relearn to walk three
times during most of 2019 my surgeon
directed me to not engage
in essentially all of the activities i
enjoy
gardening running hiking or any
significant physical activities that
would jeopardize the lengthy healing
process required
for me to be
put back together
the driver's reckless conduct
conduct for basic standards of public
safety
also directly impacted my responsibility
as asgardian to my now 26 year old son
forest
due to my original injuries for nine
straight months i was unable to support
my son at all
a young man who needs just a little bit
of an extra helping hand to make his way
in our beautiful granite state
due to ongoing surgeries seven eight
nine and ten over the last two and a
half years
my ability to support him has been
intermittent at best
my most recent surgery was on december
30th just a few months ago in 2021
as executive director of a small
non-profit my ability to perform my job
effectively
has no doubt been significantly impacted
and i love my job i love what i do
not only my job
but the future of the organization were
put in jeopardy due to that moment of
distraction of the of that careless
driver
again for the better part of a year i
was not able to perform the basic tasks
that we take for granted every day
i didn't shower i didn't go to the
second floor of my house i couldn't cook
a meal i couldn't use a bathroom toilet
i didn't sleep in my own bed and i
couldn't even wear pants
my children wept through christmas
i was unable to ride as a passenger in a
car because of the external fixator for
four months
my life now still includes physical
therapy
and there will be
three more surgeries in my future
the total costs now exceed a million
dollars
every single moment is still
rigorously
demanding
relearning to walk is excruciatingly
hard and this latest round since
december
has been particularly rugged
snowy sidewalks are now scary stairs are
mountains and i'll tell you all night
long my right knee and my left hip take
turns telling me exactly how they feel
i have a fierce and effervescent
love for this fabulous gift called life
yet mine is forever changed i was
personally and professionally isolated
in my home or in the hospital
from december
2018 until
september of 2019 i was at risk for
losing my job and those who depended on
me were without my help
i wonder about people of low
socioeconomic status who end up in
situations like this
the non-profit i worked for gave me two
months of paid leave and allowed me to
work from home how does a waitress or an
employee of walmart
or a mechanic in a car shop or any
minimum wage or or low wage worker
not go broke or avoid homelessness if
they are put into a recovery process
like mine
distracted drivers inflict harsh
financial
impacts beyond the physical costs of the
injuries costs of the physical injuries
i'd also like to let you know that first
responders who train for hours to save
strangers
people they don't know or love are
harmed by distracted drivers
they go into extremely stressful scenes
like mine scenes they can never unsee
to serve our communities to provide
physical and emotional support to
traumatized survivors
they are true superheroes living in our
midst the chief in
in amherst said to me
car crashes like yours are what make or
break new recruits
people leave public service as first
responders when they see accidents like
mine
the driver who hit me served 60 days
in jail
because current statute does not provide
prosecutors the discretion they need to
file for a class b felony in those cases
where serious bodily injury or death
occurs
we must work together to put really
sharp teeth into the penalties for
causing serious bodily injury
and sharpen the public's awareness of
how serious distracted driving has
become
i hope this committee finds sb 306 ought
to pass
so those who are prone to distracted
driving are deterred from making a
reckless and senseless choice that would
force another family
to endure what mine has
thank you
they give your testimony
the committee now calls lieutenant brian
strong new hampshire state police
i'm confused
wallace
who did i say was in for sure didn't i
say something
good morning mr chairman
and members
good morning my name is brian strong i
am a lieutenant with the new hampshire
department of safety division of state
police
i'm currently assigned as our
commander of our special investigations
unit and within the special
investigations unit is where a collision
analysis reconstruction unit
is located
they are responsible for investigating
serious bodily injury crashes and
fatalities throughout the state of new
hampshire
early on in my career i was part of this
reconstruction unit for 12 years where i
investigated hundreds of crashes
to include serious bodily injury and
fatalities throughout the state of new
hampshire
i am here today on behalf of the
division of state police to support sb
new hampshire as a state has come a long
way with handling distracted drivers
distracted driver is one of the top
three causes of serious bodily injury
and fatality crashes in new hampshire
and pretty much throughout the country
i believe our hands-free law went into
effect back in 2015
in a hem in an attempt to help reduce
distractions
uh and crashes
now this law hasn't stopped everyone
from using the hands uh handheld devices
while driving
but has definitely reduced that type of
behavior
i believe by adding the proposed
language uh
that's outlined
outlined uh
in rsa 650 or excuse me by adding the
proposed language to rsa 651 colon 2 to
those offenses that are listed in the
proposed 265 265a and 630 coin 3 which
are based on facts
and prohibited use of mobile electronic
devices while driving a motor vehicle
would be subject to enhance offenses
outlined in this bill
i believe this is another way that we
can help curb this type of behavior by
increasing the penalties for certain
violations and also letting people know
that should you decide
to use electronic mobile device while
driving
uh and are involved in a crash usually
subject to to face more severe penalties
now by by no means by adding this
language is gonna stop this
from happening around the state
we hope to curb it and reduce the
numbers
and i think this is one step further
that we can take as a state
thank you
representative manjuputi
thank you mr chair um
thank you uh lieutenant for taking my
question
back in
when uh hands-free
restriction or distracted driving
bill was passed
what kind of penalty would did that have
is it wasn't it just a
ticket in that time
also we had the
data
from the police
yes
thank you for the question uh back in
2015 and i think it's even current today
that should you um be charged with using
a mobile device it's just a violation
it's a fine there is a second or
subsequent offense in the third offense
it just elevates the dollar amount
should you be uh should you be charged
follow mr chair
you're still recognized thank you um
would would you still have that data
that you know it was presented i was on
this committee at that time
number of crashes number of uh
um crowd data based on
crashes and who was using texting
minutes before the crash that kind of
data
do you still have that available
so thank you for the question i
currently do not have that
with me currently but i believe uh
within department of safety
that uh that data should be available um
yes
thank you
representative boardney
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um
i'm really not familiar with a lot of
the transportation uh
laws so um can you tell me what
constitutes a class a misdemeanor in
this uh bill
so if you look in and i don't have the
uh my rsa book in front of me but i
think if you look under the negligent
homicide the 630 colon three it's gonna
outline uh probably uh what classifies a
misdemeanor or a b felony
uh the other violations on the 265 265a
which are outlined in this
those i believe
uh that primarily are um
violations uh
the dwi statute i think is under that
that would uh
this potential to elevate that
and i don't have my book in front of me
so that there might be another one i'm
sorry that i don't have that in front of
me
all right so basically it is a uh
uh bodily injury uh type of accident
that you're that someone is involved in
and they caused it is that is that what
i hear
for the elevated uh no just for class a
misdemeanor
without the elevation
is as far as i'm reading
this statute here in front of me and let
me just get to it it looks like it's
uh it looks like it's adding all
these rsas the 265 to 265a
right the 265 is rules of the road i
believe and
and that would be majority of them i
think of violations
like for speeding i think that falls
under that statute for
for rules of the road some of the ones
that are elevated would be like your
dwis
and i believe they have enhancements for
serious bodily injury and fatalities
your negligent homicide there is
enhanced penalties for that also
and again i'm sorry i don't have my my
book in front of me to to clarify
further
representative bourdain
uh i thank you um
i i guess i'm i'm a little concerned
when we're moving from a penalty of a
class a misdemeanor to a felony i would
like to really know what we're talking
about
again i don't have my the actual
books in front of me for the statutes
but i think if you look under 6 30
colon 3 for the negligent homicide
there's a certain statute and it'll say
what the the penalty is
we are looking to see if there is a if
the mobile device is involved in the and
the causation of the crash that it goes
up one step from where it currently is
thank you very much
representative newman
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um
when one of these violations are
appear to be have been broken
if there is a crash or an accident or
whatever it is and the police arrive on
the scene
and
they arrest or detain somebody
um
when when is the person charged so it
because it says when they are charged
that these enhancements may be made
when when does a person that that has
been involved in an accident like that
charge could you just kind of explain
that process to me so that i know when
this would actually take effect because
it probably would sure when when they're
charged absolutely so from my experience
and
i was many years on our uh accident
reconstruction unit um
when we go out it's it's for the most
severe and heinous crashes in the state
primarily those take lengthy
investigations and obviously to uh to
actually make a determination somebody's
on a cell phone at the time of the crash
would not probably be made at the time
of the crash you would have to look for
further investigation into that so there
would be an investigation before
probably likely a charge
uh would come out of it i can't speak
for every case because every case would
have certain or different circumstances
some would be quicker uh probably to
come to a resolution and some may be a
little longer
does that answer uh this follow-up
you recognize for a follow-up
in in instances where there may not be
any injury is it is it likely that the
person would be not not be charged that
day and would be released what's the
likelihood when there is no injury of
being charged
in
uh so again i can't speak for everybody
in every police department out there as
whether they'll charge somebody right on
scene or if they're going to
charge them
with
a certain violation
i think the
the moral of of this bill here is to
try to curb people from actually using
devices and i think if they're
aware of that of the enhanced penalties
um that may help curb
the use of it it's not going to
completely stop it i'll be frank it's
not complete but if it if it curbs
you know uh a few a handful a certain
percentage
um
i think that's a win
thank you
representative marston
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking our questions
i'm interested in finding out how we're
going to enforce this law for a starter
how do we enforce it
as far as that as far as the hands-free
law or as far as enforcing uh increased
penalties any pot yes any part of this
bill how are we going to enforce it so i
believe the first step within enforcing
is actually to get it on the books so
then there is a way to to enforce it and
then when we have serious bodily injury
crashes uh there is a lot of
communications with either the county
attorney or the attorney general's
office depending on the case at hand
and they make a lot of the uh
determinations and factual uh decisions
for certain charges
follow-up mr chairman you're so
recognized for a follow-up thank you
what i don't understand in your answer
has to do with the fact that
when you're doing a reconstruction
investigation
are we using every tool at your disposal
such as getting warrants for the
person's phone for just a simple example
absolutely
thank you
representative hearn
thank you mr chair thank you
for picking my question
first question i guess would be is
in 2015 when the uh
law was passed for the
whole device there was a big push there
was a lot of advertisements
move that closer
hear me now
okay sorry about that
uh back in 2015 uh there was a big push
there was a lot of
advertisement to push for the uh
these tickets i mean to write tickets to
make people aware
i guess the question i have is since
then
is the enforcement of writing tickets
still there
statistically or has it dropped off
i i don't have complete statistics uh
going back as 2015 and uh and just
briefly before i tried to gather some
statistics uh coming in here in case i
was asked
in 2020 it looks like there was 4 673
uh
tickets uh or citations issued for
hands-free violations in 2021 so a year
earlier
um
or actually your year
later got 20 20 21 so a year later i'm
sorry uh it's 39.89 so we've uh
it has been it has been uh reduced
like i said you know there's going to be
people that are continue going to
continue to do it just like
the speed limits are certain people are
going to
you know push the limits so
representative hearn
so i guess my question is is the same
thing is going to happen in from 2015.
we're going to have a big push and then
all of a sudden it's just going to drop
off and the enforcement is not going to
be there
i can't speak on the enforcement i can
tell you that for the state police i've
been here 22 years uh we take
enforcement serious um and we do pushes
out there and um
i know we have uh um
certain you know patrols that we go to i
say target but look for people that are
using mobile devices
representative manju puti thank you mr
chair a follow-up to uh representative
o'haran uh you said in 2021
uh number dropped but it was also in the
middle of pandemic when a lot of people
were working from home
so the data from 20 to 21
would that have affected
thank you for your question i i guess
that's possible and i don't have um i
don't have the previous years to to go
back i'm sure the data is available i'm
sure we could easily get the data if you
needed to look at it i just don't have
it with me
representative burt
thank you mr chairman
why wouldn't we why won't this bill
enhance all distracted driving and not
just
the hands-free part because i've seen
people
you know eating food putting on makeup
uh reading newspapers up through the
tolls that was a funny one um
you know i mean there's a lot of
distracted that could cause accidents
and do you know the separation of how
many accidents are
caused in distracted driving laws
how many are the hands you know the cell
phones and how many are
eating a banana reading newspapers you
know is there a separation there do you
keep track of that
thank you for your question um i don't
have that data with me i believe that
that is tracked uh however i don't know
definitively because i am not a person
responsible for tracking the data
um i am aware of you know your
uh your examples of other people
putting on makeup
eating
reading yeah that happens
there are a lot of distractions that
drivers um
put themselves in
um
there's probably more that the state can
do
to uh make the rules
of the road safer
this is one of them because a mobile
phone
wherever you go
is attached and glued to just about
everybody
and some people live on their phone to
include when they're driving and i think
if we can curb that
that will help
is it going to curb everything no
there's probably more that we can do
but it's a start
all right thank you
representative connolly thank you mr
chairman thank you for taking the
question we've heard enforcement come up
several times
uh forgive me if you address this
already can you
explain how the department would even
get to a place where they would want to
subpoena phone records to even know
whether a phone would be involved how do
you even get to that point so you have
to have so sorry thank you for your
question so first of all uh you have to
have some type of um
you know articulate suspicion or uh
reasonable grounds to believe that a
phone was in use so obviously if there's
a crash and there is no phone anywhere
you just can't jump to
uh we're going to um we're going to look
for that most likely there'll be a phone
present you your you talk to witnesses
there's a process to go around
to get us to that point and then you
have to apply for you know certain legal
process to get records cell phones data
etc and all that uh when we reach those
thresholds we follow up with those
parameters to ensure
we can
look to see if somebody was on the phone
uh at the time of the crash
representative conley thank you and so
knowing that there is an established
process for uh determining if a phone
was involved does that stand to reason
that that same process would dictate how
one would be charged with these enhanced
penalties if the law worked if this bill
were to pass
so there's a process in place and that
process would continue
if this passes we're just talking about
the
punishment that would go to the offender
is that correct yes thank you for your
question uh that is absolutely correct
because the process for investigating is
not going to change it's just going to
be the penalty phase thank you
representative rory
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
so
there's a lot i think there's confusion
regarding what constitutes um unlawful
use of a device i think a lot of people
under the misconception that just
because you put it in a holder and it's
not in your hand anymore could you
explain to us
and and the public at large what what
constitutes what is legal and what is
not legal with regard to using a phone
or any electronic device in the car sure
thank you for your question
basically obviously anything handheld
because it's handheld mobile devices
anything that's actually going to be in
your hand that you are using to text
phone call
uh
communicate read now there are phones
that are put into a holder that will go
through bluetooth um
that is eliminating the hands-free
manipulating the actual phone while
you're driving that's where you're gonna
have the issues when you've got to
actually manipulate the phone you're
gonna look down for a brief second or
longer to manipulate it so it's the
actual
um
manipulation of actually the phone um
to you know dialing to make phone calls
texting reading the text messages
um
the actual
course of physically using a handheld
device
and just quick follow-up so for example
if i have my phone in the holder it's
one of those cup deals that it's pretty
convenient
it's not in my hand
but if i look over
and answer a text that is that still
technically a violation of the law as it
stands
thank you for your question i would say
i believe yes i'd have to just
re-clarify um yes but i do know some
people use their phones they put it up
on the dash for gps so it's up there
it's navigating
okay thank you
representative conley thank you
just piggybacking on what my colleague
just asked uh
many cars with the bluetooth you know
goes through the bluetooth it ends up on
your screen and there's some
manipulation involved
does that constitute would that trigger
this law
you know to dictate it you sometimes
press a bunch of buttons
thank you for your question uh i would
have to research that further uh off uh
initial inclination i would probably say
probably not because a lot of the cars
have
uh
mobile screens now
um and and there are touching you know
you are manipulating that as you're
driving you turning the radio you're
checking for you're moving through the
screen so
i would have to look for uh
clarification on that thank you
um thank you uh one one more question
and this kind of brings me back to what
representative burr asked it seems like
we're we're chasing technology here um
every time we we pass a law technology
advances and now we're back out of it
again
wouldn't it be better if we if we more
generalize distracted driving so that we
didn't necessarily pin it to a specific
set of circumstances
um in other words i can text from my
screen that's built into the car now
there's so many things i can do these
cars have become you know it's like a
spaceship
so
you you're still distracted whether it's
in your hand or it's there
what do you feel about making it more
general instead of tying it just to a
certain set of explicit circumstances
thank you for your question personally
i think that would be good
we have
negligent driving there's a statute for
negligent driving and that would
or could
uh encompass people that are
driving and doing other things besides
paying attention
um
the biggest thing is is
really the phones and i think tackling
that
um
is a monster in and of itself um and
you're right technology is always going
to be changing
um
the phones are changing um
that you'd be hard-pressed to walk
anywhere
and and see somebody not having a phone
or
or on a phone you can't even go to
dinner now and everybody look at a booth
and they're not even talking across from
the person they're sitting next to
they're down
their life is their phone
i think that's a
one that should definitely be targeted i
hate to use word targeted but should be
actually uh
looked at
thank you
there be no further questions thank you
for your testimony thank you
the committee now calls holly haynes
thank you my apologies thank you
chairman abbas and honorable members of
this committee my name is holly heens
i'm a former president of the new
hampshire association for justice and
i'm an attorney in manchester new
hampshire
representing
many victims of
car crashes
like ms bowden who have been injured
catastrophically by distracted drivers
before i begin my testimony i've just
distributed written testimony for all of
you and i believe that page two may
answer some of the questions that
representative
mangapudi had
and i hope to be able to answer some
other questions but i want to make sure
that we understand exactly what this
bill does
[Music]
we may have gone a little bit of field
because it's not creating any new laws
regarding mobile electronic devices it's
not creating any new crimes at all all
that it does is
give prosecutors additional discretion
when they are charging offenses after
a crash has happened after an offense
has already happened and it gives judges
additional discretion at sentencing
for example one of the questions were
what are examples of violations that
would be elevated or class a felon uh
misdemeanors that might be elevated
rsa 265 79 is reckless driving
rsa26579b is negligent driving both of
those right now are considered
violations under new hampshire law those
would be elevated to class b
misdemeanors
rsa 265 79a is vehicular assault and
that is currently a class b misdemeanor
that would be elevated to class a
these types of violations and ms
bowden's case um
i believe that the driver was charged
with reckless driving and vehicular
assault he received a minor fine and 60
days in jail she as you just heard has
been dealing with this for three years
now
more than a dozen surgeries and she's
going to be dealing with it for the rest
of her life i have to say that justice
was not served in her case in any way
shape or form
the benefit of this it's not changing
crimes it's not adding crimes it's just
reflective of the societal outrage now
at distracted driving the public safety
issue that we have similar to in the
1980s the
societal outrage we had against drunk
and drugged driving in response to that
we changed our criminal code we added
discretionary enhanced penalties for
aggravated distract aggravated drunk
driving excuse me when a drunk driver
caused an injury caused an accident
with serious bodily injury or death the
prosecutor has a discretion to charge it
both as
the
regular drunk driving offense or
aggravated or the vehicular assault
offense it just gives the prosecutor
added discretion to
enhance the charge and it gives the
judge added discretion to enhance the
penalty at the end it's not going to
change anything
with regard to the actual crash itself
the investigation by the police or the
state police or the enforcement as we
saw after
drunk driving and drug driving laws were
enhanced the incidences of drunk driving
have decreased it has made our roadways
safer
that's exactly what we're asking to do
with this bill with distracted driving
it will make our roadways safer if
prosecutors have the discretion and
drivers know that if this happens and
they cause a crash that harm someone
like lisa bowden or any other citizen of
the state
they may be going to jail for it they
are going to have enhanced penalties and
they're going to have something
they're going to recognize truly be
punished and hopefully this will have to
turn effect from them thriving
distracted
as you heard from lisa there are so many
secondary harms that no one thinks about
from distracted driving we're just
thinking about what is a mobile device
what are people doing what are they
texting
people are losing their lives they're
losing their limbs they're losing their
loved ones some families lisa incurred
more than a million dollars in medical
bills this driver was not insured did
not have enough insurance to compensate
her
in a case like that
families can be put into financial ruin
with medical debt the driver spent 60
days in jail and now he's back to his
day job working every day
not thinking twice about what happened
to lisa lisa and her family are going to
live with us for the rest of their lives
if this was someone in a service
industry
for example a waitress
a
car mechanic someone who doesn't have a
an employer accommodating like lisa's
was that was able to give her some
flexibility with her job they would not
only go into financial room for medical
debt but they would from
inability to have their own income
while the offender is going back to work
right after
this is a critical bill
that we need to deter distracted driving
it will have a benefit to public safety
and i think is something that everyone
can get behind it's not going to change
the burdens approved for prosecutors at
all other than they'll have to prove the
prohibited use of an electronic device
it just gives them an added charging
mechanism
prosecutors often bring multiple
variants of charges lesser included
offenses when they charge defendants and
that this is just going to give them a
higher elevation of a charge of an
offense to charge at the same time and i
just want to emphasize that it is just a
discretionary
option for prosecutors and for judges at
sentencing this isn't mandatory
it just gives prosecutors and judges
more discretion to enforce the laws
enhance the deterrent effect of
distracted driving and increase public
safety
thank you for your time and i'm happy to
take questions
a question from the chair
in miss badoy's case
did she did the did the perpetrator
receive the maximum sentence available
at the time he did not and we actually
the um
police prosecutor from the amherst
police department was
reticent because of the limits on the
laws to ask the judge for additional
penalties i asked him to ask for
restitution to ask for the maximum jail
time to ask for the maximum fine and he
was reticent to do that
ultimately i asked the judge for that on
lisa's behalf and the judge declined to
um order restitution because he found if
someone was in jail they wouldn't be
able to work and they wouldn't be able
to pay restitution and this person did
not have funds you can't get blood from
a stone i believe would be the quote
from the judge
and i don't think that reflects justice
if this was available and
to the prosecutor
i believe that he would have asked for
the additional charges and the
additional sentences it's because it
wasn't available he had never done it
before and he was concerned about what
the judge would do that he didn't ask
for additional penalties
and a quick follow-up you mentioned he
didn't have insurance
was he required to for any reason have
insurance but didn't have it or was he
just not opting and legally not obliged
to have it so i want to correct one
statement he was underinsured he had a
minimal policy um i don't believe he was
required to have insurance because he
owned his truck it was an older metal
truck and wasn't subject to financing
and he wasn't under sr-22 thank you
representative
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
i guess it's on the same level as
you know so you're telling me um
that there was
more penalties they could have gone
after but they
the prosecutor elected not to is that
correct
um
ultimately the case resolved i believe
in a plea bargain for the defendant and
that may have been one of the reasons
but the penalties weren't higher for
incarceration i believe 60 days may have
been the maximum i'm not sure about that
i'm not a criminal prosecutor so i don't
want to misspeak about that
in a follow-up mr chairman
thank you
mr chairman um
so with the current laws
what could he have gotten for jail time
the full if if
if they didn't take a plea deal
so for reckless driving
it's a violation and it is a
fine of no more than 750 for a first
offense
and no less than 500 plus penalty
assessment
and loss of license for 60 days
for the vehicular assault charge
it's a class day misdemeanor and
actually it doesn't say but i believe
that that's a fine of up to a
thousand dollars and i'm not sure of the
time for the jail time i think that
there are criminal lawyers who may be
able to speak to that that are here
today all right all right thank
you representative mans pudding
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question i have two part questions
one is back in 2015
when initially the distracted driving
law was
enforced or passed
was also considered
for the vehicles do they have that
bluetooth
option or hands-free option because
up until then not all vehicles
had that option
has that changed
um
now i know personally i had to change my
car because i didn't have the bluetooth
um
so
that one
and the
or do you want me to ask the second
question after
uh thank you for that question i don't
know the answer to your first question
so if you'd like to ask your second
question second question is about at
that time
you know distracted driving included
a generic
overarching but the data at that time
that we got on this committee was
predominantly the deaths due to crash in
few seconds before the crash happened
they had the data on texting use of
uh mobile phone
at that time so that was the predominant
cause for the fatal crop crash to have
any of those
data
so what i did present in my testimony on
page two is the information from the
national highway traffic and safety
institute
they do keep data on distracted driving
and crashes
not just involving injury
the average since 2017 there are almost
a million crashes every year caused by
distracted driving or use of mobile
electronic devices
though of those crashes more than 400
000 involve injuries and 3 000 involved
deaths in new hampshire alone
the data i have is from 2017 i suspect
it's probably similar it may have gone
down in 2020 or 2021 because of less
people on the roadway but there were 9
000 crashes a year as of 2017 and 2018
that were involving the use of mobile
electronic devices and distracted
driving
one last follow-up mr chen
last one
thank you
how many other states have
instituted this
i do not know the answer to that
question representative i'm sorry
representative newman
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
i'll just not see you but that'll be
okay
um
you described i get in your written
testimony and and the testimony you gave
here about
the um
the way this person was charged and um
could you just elaborate on that a
little bit that that
the judge is the one that made it made a
charge and
you mentioned something about the
amherst police department in a
discussion could you just kind of clear
that up for me yes thank you very much
representative um
after a crash the amherst police
department investigated the crash and it
ultimately amherst does not have a
legal prosecutor they have a police
prosecutor who's a captain in the police
in the amherst police department he is
who makes the charging decisions based
upon the information that was gathered
at the crash and ultimately he brings
the charges against the defendant and he
and the defense attorney reached a plea
agreement on the charges and then it's
brought to the judge for sentencing and
the judge can either accept or reject
the plea agreement
thank you
there'd be no further questions thank
you for your testimony thank you so much
thank you members of the committee
the committee now calls bonnie dunham
hi my name is bonnie dunham and i'm here
in support of this bill
and and lisa's a friend of mine and i've
seen some of the horrendous impact of
the crash that she was in it wasn't an
accident somebody on purpose decided
that using a cell phone was more
important than her life and so
i i think that
much of what i've written here has been
already said so i won't repeat it um but
i think that it's unacceptable that
somebody should be allowed to
put their convenience before someone
else's life their livelihood their
family's well-being
and all of the contributions that that
individual somebody like lisa could make
to society and instead had to spend that
time
going through surgery after surgery
fighting for her life physical therapy
and having pain as her constant
companion
the impact on her family has been
horrendous and the impact on the
community because of about the kinds of
things that she does in her line of work
and in her
free time
the deterrent that this driver
experienced was so low i honestly can't
think of how it would discourage him
from doing it again i don't know if he
has but
it i don't see that being a deterrent to
him and certainly not to others who i
think this is an opportunity to send a
message to people that if you do this if
you put yourself before
the
life of other people just because you
choose to act irresponsibly then you
will face a serious penalty um and just
have it be loud enough that other people
will hear it and change their behavior
that's all
thank you
thank you for your testimony
is there anyone else here wishing to
testify who's not testified on this bill
come forward sir thank you
mom could you fill out a pin card for
him
hi my name is forrest
darwin friday i am
representing
and delivering
my brother's testimony he is in college
now
um
dear chairman abbas and honorable
members of the committee
i appreciate the opportunity to speak
today
i'm asking you to support
senate bill 306 on
december
19th 2018
at 11 41 pm
i received a
call saying my mom
had been in a terrible car
accident she was alive
but it was bad
i felt
completely lost
powerless to help
and desperate for
answers that simply were not coming
my mother's life was forever
changed in ways that i cannot
begin to comprehend
and our family still
grapples with new difficult discoveries
on a regular basis as a result of the
crash one person's decision to
endanger the life of another by using a
mobile device affects not
always
that person but also the lives of all
the people around them
i spent christmas eve after
the crash lying awake in the dark at the
hospital on a make shift pull out chair
wondering
if my
mom would live
to see the new year
in an instant a stranger's decision to
use his phone had taken away my family's
ability
to find any peace
or happiness at christmas
we didn't get to choose
where to have sleep last
night
waiting for
mom to get out of surgery
now every time i get a phone call at
night
i'm afraid to pick it up
i imagine answering
two
news that my brother
forest
has been hit by a car
i don't get to choose
when people call
when they do
i find myself ramped from a normal
situation into moments of terror and
insecurity
over the past three years my family's
sentence of
uncertainty and
pain has been oppressively
constant
hours and doctor's appointments
on the phone with
healthcare providers emptying bad
parents
she wasn't able to
pursue her life as she wished
we have been at the
mercy of the consequences
of a distracted
drivers a selfish and irresponsible
ashes for over 1
100 days
and contrast
the distracted driver who caused the
crash allowed to
self-report
in may 2019
to serve him that his
day sentence
a measly
day stat test for utterly and
irrevocably
altering the
lives of
countless other people
why does he get to choose
when we do that
when we do not
how can
this committee possibly claim to see any
justice in his sentence
the srs
it cannot
for there is not to be seen
new hampshire's current penalties
for distracted driving are have hearted
imitations of justice
that pale and
credibility
before the
incomparably
towering
and
far reaching
consequences of the crime
the legislation needs to change
as a son
whose mother who was on the receiving
end of a vehicular assault i implore you
to
support
asp306
in
favor of stricter penalties
for
perpetrators of the heinous
irresponsible and yet completely
preventable decision to
drive recklessly
thank you and i am looking forward to
questions
representative mains putin
thank you mr chair
thank you forrester for taking my
question
and you read your brother's testimony
or your sentiments very similar to your
own
if you could write a testimony would it
be same
well um
my brother laura just
moved to college at wesleyan
university
um
yeah i i am very similar to rowan
because my
i i am just um
representing rowan
because he is in college
now
can i rephrase my question too
okay
um
let me ask you this way sir forest
sorry
okay sir
um what i felt
is
that
and i i
if this was in 2018
and um
i
my brother rowan called me
about my mom
um i was
um and i was
in peterborough for five years
and
um
and um i heard about my mom's accident
um and reflected
on may um
i
knew that um this would um
make me feel a little bit um
nervous to see about um
how
my mom
was in a car accident
because
it made me feel like what you are seeing
here in these pictures
because um
i just um
felt um a little bit um
disappointed about what
how my mom
felt where she um got herself in a
position to
hurt herself
thank you very much for your testimony
today we appreciate it
the chair has a question of
attorney haynes if you if she's still
here
she didn't okay all right thank you
there being no one else to testify oh
you want to testify
hello and thank you i'll be very brief
um i'll need you to fill out a pin card
when you're done okay well my name is
tina beaudwin i'm lisa bodwin's sister i
got the first call
when she had been helicoptered in
i think we've
um
i'm in full support of this bill not
only was my sister hit and it was been
horrific surgeries and the amount of
pain
and
it obviously the
the repercussions for the man who hit
her are nowhere near justice i don't
know if all of you feel this way i'm
nervous when i drive i constantly see
distracted drivers
constantly i myself was hit by a car
on august 29th
eight months ago i'm on a bicycle by a
distracted driver it's rampant the
they barely got i think they got a
moving violation there was no
consequences very low fines but for all
of us and our families i think we have
to do a bit but better to safeguard our
families and the entire community and
making um
the consequences more severe when people
are operating a vehicle and cause
serious injuries thank you for
everyone's time and consideration
thank you for your testimony
is there anyone else wishing to testify
who has not yet testified on this bill
there be none i hereby close the public
hearing
the committee be in recess for 10
minutes
okay
you know
yeah okay
okay
come on
at this time i'm going to open the
work session on
sv 294.
and i'm gonna open the floor up does
anyone have any
discussion they'd like to have on this
representative
newman
thank you mr chair
i've stated a lot of times my concerns
about the may and shall i've talked
about
rebuttable presumptions and all of those
kind of things
and have not been very successful with
that
so
i'm now approaching it from um what the
best bill would be to
um
what kind of changes might make it more
palatable to more people so that we the
bill comes out of committee
with a recommendation
so
in the past i've also discussed there
are a lot of
folks that are concerned
that when you have a list of crimes like
we currently do
there are there are some of those crimes
like on
domestic violence
and i can't list all the other ones from
the other ones from top of my head
where
under the title of the of the law that
we're talking about
there are a bunch of lesser
crimes with lesser penalties
that are included in that
so i thought that
probably
i could support something with this list
of laws
that
somehow took care of what i call the
lesser penalties
so
i i am suggesting and have had an
amendment drawn up
that
would say that a person who is charged
with a felony
or class a misdemeanor offense
for any of the following and then it
repeats the
the list of
laws just the way it is in the current
bill
in what those words
charged with a felony
or class a misdemeanor offense
or any of the following does
is that it includes the underlying
chart underlying things
in in the various crimes
that do not have any
uh
jail time
involved in that so it eliminates
class b misdemeanors and violations
so i thought that something like that
might be more amenable
and uh i have an amendment with that i
don't know whether to be allowed or not
thank you
does everyone have a copy of
representatives abbas amendment
yeah it does it's uh 1468 eight
newman
you weren't here for the discussion
and the
discussion i had i'll give you the
thumbnail version
i did
i could he i could hear the discussion
you could hear it okay so i said that i
had also had amendment drawn up to uh
support if it was allowed and i do have
an amendment
and if you would allow me to distribute
a copy i would but that's uh yeah thank
you oh of course
representative bourdain
yes and just to clarify the
last
fall we had a bill it was senate bill 92
and that was amendment we we passed that
with a positive recommendation this
committee
had an amendment number two one eight
zero
the amendment
it's it's very similar to that there are
two
changes and that is it at least as it's
written right now one of them is one of
the changes is there's a list of
offenses
on page 2
lines 1-20
out of those offenses listed in that
section
the felony use of a firearm was removed
and the rationale for that was as
written
is that at least the policy here is that
these often involves crimes against a
person
the way the rsa is written today the
crime
as it can be charged is a person's
merely committing a crime that happens
to be in possession of a firearm however
the firearm is unrelated to the actual
criminal act
and
if you look in our
book of rsas this fancy purple book i
looked at some of the cases cited under
that
rsa one of them was a person was
arrested with possession with intent to
distribute but because that person was
also carrying a firearm they were
charged with the felony use of a firearm
as well even though that firearm did not
actually play a role
in that offense now there there's a
federal law which is not
it has similar language to uh to the rsa
in new hampshire and the federal courts
have interpreted that that the firearm
actually has to relate to the offense
however the law in new hampshire at
least the way the courts have been
ruling have not
interpreted that way
so the reason why it's been removed is
that it's
could be applied where
you
so one of the issues is and the other
part of it is if you use a firearm to
commit robbery or if you point a firearm
at someone you're going to fall under
one of the other felony
charges on on this list anyway
so we i'm i was confident with that by
removing that we would still be honoring
what we
at least the intent of what it was to
list these offenses
what line was that mr chairman it's page
two lines one through twenty is where
the offenses are all listed
and then the other
change is
there was a section where if you get you
keep missing or
are not showing up at subsequent court
hearings
the amended version it
shortened the look back period of how
long they would look back from five
years to three
however it
there was a lot of
opposition to that uh although i don't
agree that
i i prefer the amended version
from amended from amendment number two
one eight zero
i prefer that over this
i took that section out so what is
appears on the amendment is what exists
in law is today
you hear the term rebuttable presumption
rebuttable presumption rebuttable
presumption the existing law has
the language rebuttable presumption
already in it
but
that section would not be changed by the
amendment that's being passed around
today that's amendment number 1486.
so whatever you see there is the current
law
uh
and that was that's part of a compromise
with some of the members of this
committee that i've spoken with about
that
so those are the two differences the
rest of it is
is similar and then we have a side by
side that kind of gives us a rundown of
it doesn't include this amendment
amendment 1486 but it does have
the 2180
in there
i'll probably support these but
i am
we're trying we're stepping around and
going into contortions because we've got
a system that doesn't work
with with the bail bondsmen
and bailiffs and
until we until we get rid of that
and go to uh most
either the judges or magistrate whatever
is proper
we're not going to settle this thing i i
am just so irritated at trying to step
around the crap
and to to to do this
at the point of time where we convert to
a magistrate system and i would support
that system now it has to we have to put
it all together it also has to be
financed so it's not as easy as just
putting there was some talk of even
trying to put that
system into this
into as part of an amendment to senate
bill 294
my hesitation is
one
for us to un collectively understand
that the complicated process that is
bail
there's still
issues with interpretation of an
amendment that we've had
i don't know five six work sessions on
long hearings on
if i think including that into this
system it would i thought it would have
been difficult to get us all
collectively on board to understand
how to incorporate that into the system
but i know
that that there's going to be
a push for that
i i wouldn't be surprised was in the
first year of next term
but to do it right now just this late in
the process might be difficult
and by the time it's even up and running
i mean if we don't if we don't have the
funding we didn't put fund for it in the
budget
and hb2 so without the funding for it
it's never going to get off the ground
anyway but it's something that's kind of
getting support on from
all parties
representative marston
thank you mr chairman
help me out a little bit if you will
um i spoke last night with the chief of
police in manchester who i happened to
run across
and he was telling me he's in support of
the senate bill
and it's a four-digit number that i
think bradley put out has to do with
bail reform
and is this in that conjunction i mean
i'm confused between these two this
talks about
releasing a defendant pre-trial isn't
that bail reform
that's why i'm confused
thank you
all right i i don't know what what
specific bill everyone was talking about
in that conversation
this
this is
when we say bail reform it doesn't mean
if a person gets arrested they're just
going to be held
awaiting trial no matter what they're
still going to be a bail process
there was
we all know there was
bail reform was passed a few years ago
this is trying to really address the
most egregious circumstances we're
always going to have situations where
you know you hear about these stories
and then you see the news that one that
always stuck stuck out to me and it was
an unfortunate situation someone was
arrested five times
in a two-month time period for drunk
driving
that i think we without knowing the
details of each of those arrests to me
was pretty clear that person was
i made the presumption that that person
was struggling with something else going
on
to get arrested that many times in that
short of a time period that person was
becoming a danger to themselves and to
the public
and i got a phone call about what what
are we going to do to try to address
that and they wanted they were talking
about penalties for drunk driving
that's the that's if the person's found
guilty but until you're found guilty
each of each arrest was for a first
offense
the issue was was how many times was
that person going to get bail
before we did something to try to help
the person
the way this is written
and if you look at it's
on page 3
lines fourteen to twenty seven
on the amendment or the bill the the
amendment
page three lines fourteen to 27.
and that's in that situation on the
third offense
that person would have
would have likely been held now
they would have been had the opportunity
to rebut
the presumption that they would not
violate the conditions of their release
which was
don't get arrested for a new offense
they would have had the opportunity to
do that
and perhaps they could have overcome
that i suppose if they were arrested in
a fourth time it would have been much
more difficult to overcome that
this has has drunk driving class a
misdemeanors and felonies it excludes
other class b misdemeanors the rationale
is
if you would not go to serve any jail
time as a potential penalty
should that be an appropriate reason to
have your
to be held
the argument is that you're still
violating the conditions of your release
but that wouldn't count as one of the
violations
of that
so
would you just repeat the line number
lines 14 to 27 on page 3 of the
amendment
so
if i can direct everyone's attention to
page two lines one through twenty
there's a if you see the list of
offenses
a lot of people have brought up
that that includes misdemeanors
the misdemeanors that are included is
stalking and domestic violence
just to point that out and i guess my
question is
is that does anyone have any is that a
hold up for anyone is that a concern
that someone has
representative ray newman
um
let me address this part of it first i
was going to ask something about your
third opinion but i'll go back to that
so i i do have a concern and i've voiced
it many times along with all the other
stuff so but for the other stuff is not
important to me but
not catching the lower offenses is
important to me
so i and
i have an amendment that's drawn up
everybody's got a copy of it it only has
it has two changes one is to change it
to 36 hours and that's in your amendment
somewhere in there 36 hours even if the
number's there i'm happy with that
and the way
the only other changes to the first
sentence
of the list of crimes that are included
in this
it currently reads a person who is
charged with murder or any of the
following
is how it currently exists
the language that
i have had inserted says
a person who is charged with a felony
or a class a misdemeanor offense
for any of the
did i read that
i've got the wrong thing here
representative i can ask a question so
what i'm asking for right now is what's
proposing this the amendment that gets
passed around
i'm talking about 1486.
the list of offenses has two
types of misdemeanors stalking
and domestic violence
and i'm asking is there anyone in this
that's sitting on this committee today
that that is the hold up
on supporting this and the reason why
i'm being i'm asking the question is
it's if
my goal is
that we work together on this and put
something out that we all
at least as much of us as possible can
agree on
but
if that's a to me that's a real tough
pill so i have a real i struggle with
the concept of removing domestic
violence from this list i really do
but
if i'm going to make that concession i
would expect
i would expect this to pass with an
overwhelming support in the committee
if it's not i would be less inclined to
make that
can i
represent newman
yeah so and i didn't read the entire
list of the included ones under domestic
violence that's
that's the sensitive one i think
is
is there any charge in the domestic
violence
bill the way it's listed here
that
the penalty
would be a violation or a class b
misdemeanor
because that's the essence of of the the
change i would like to see
which says that
when you consider any of these laws you
it has to have a penalty of a class a
misdemeanor
a class a misdemeanor or offense for any
of the following
so it would exclude
all of the little crimes wherever they
happen to be in these bills if it's a
violation
or a class b misdemeanor because it does
include class a misdemeanors under all
of those laws i'm just trying to get to
the same place you are well i think
you're mix and match in the sections
when you're talking about if you keep
getting arrested for subsequent offenses
after being released that does not
necessarily have to invoke domestic
violence uh with this section on i'm
talking page two one through
that has to if you were arrested for any
of those offenses
you would be held
and brought before a judge you would not
be brought before a bail commission
that's all that it that's all that it's
doing
at that point the state would have the
option the prosecutor can ask that the
person be detained that the prosecutor
would have to demonstrate by clear and
convincing evidence that the person is a
threat to themselves or someone else the
rationale for
keeping misdemeanor domestic violence
is that
it's an offense that's often repeated
and if the person has a several prior
arrests for misdemean domestic violence
just because it's not amounting to a
felony does not mean the person is not
committing
a violent crime against
a household member or family member or
someone they're in a relationship with
so i just wanted to ask a semantic
question of you you just said a
misdemeanor
you didn't distinguish it between a and
b so the term misdomina includes class b
misdemeanors and is that correct what
you just said
it it doesn't list
class b misdemeanors it doesn't say that
it doesn't even say misdemeanor here i'm
just saying it lists the rsa so 631
colon 2-b but it has it it has penalties
and i'm i'm getting there okay
i'm not aware of it being a mr class b
misdemeanor
so there are uh they're all classes okay
they're all quite
and that's all i'm saying i'll find the
one with the i just
don't want whatever
thank you
representative rhodes thank you mr
chairman so i i have a question for
representative newman
and
so you
representative you had mentioned
and there was some discussion after that
so i'm trying to go back and remember
you had mentioned that
in other
i think you said miscellaneous or or or
non-serious i don't know your exact
words and i don't want to i don't want
to misquote you that you said are
throughout this throughout this
legislation can you give me an example
of something that you mean
i have i haven't done i can't go back up
top my head and figure all that out
given some time i could find out if
there are any because my understanding
is that it basically that the whole bill
is talking about
these serious crimes we all keep on
saying that we're that we all do believe
that
need to be taken
taken more seriously which is which is
why this bill is in front of us so i'm
just i'm trying to understand what maybe
what your thought is on
less serious but i don't want to put
words in your mouth or assume something
that you're saying that you're not
i will try to find an answer to your
question okay thank you thank you
i believe we have someone from the
attorney general's office here today
that can maybe
offer some comment if he doesn't mind
thank you mr chair um just as to
representative newman's question about
the difference between the class a and
whether or not there's any class b
misdemeanors encompassed within this
list
with respect to domestic violence under
631 2b
the statute says clearly in paragraph
two that domestic violence is a class a
misdemeanor unless there's a deadly
weapon used and then it can become a
felony and with respect to stalking 633
3a under paragraph 6 b of that statute
it says very specifically stalking is a
class
a misdemeanor it can become a felony if
it's a subsequent offense but in the
first instance the class a misdemeanor
so for both of those those statutes that
are cited make clear that those crimes
are class a misdemeanors and and there's
no mention of class b misdemeanor
variants of those offenses within the
statutes that delineate what the crime
is
uh
representative roy a question of the
representative of the attorney general's
office
um do you have a copy of the amendment
we're discussing in front of you i do
could you
look through um page two
paragraph one lines one through twenty
are there any offenses in there listed
that are not at least a class a
misdemeanor
again what i had just done was focused
on those two as they were referenced
domestic violence or but first degree
assaults a felony second degree assaults
a felony aggravated felony and sexual
assault and felonious sexual assault are
felonies kidnapped kidnappings of felony
we talked about stalking
i am almost certain trafficking in
persons is a felony but i would double
check that just because i don't deal
with it often
uh robberies of felony child sex abuse
images are felonies and and so are 649b
crimes
thank you
representative welch
as its answer your earlier question
which was quite a while ago domestic
violence and stalking should definitely
be on that list because domestic
violence
no matter what the occasion is it's a
very emotional thing
and the emotion dies after a period of
time
and if they release out on bail it'll
just be a repeat and it could be a fatal
one
i agree with you 100 representative
welch and domestic violence is a crime
that tends to escalate
it it's
when it's repeated it's it goes up not
down
the only suggestion i was making was if
that's the only hang up
of
keeping us divided and not perhaps
keeping this off consent
it's a it's a concession worth
discussing
but if if there are members of the
committee that
when someone's asking to take those out
and it they're still not going to
support it i'm not really sure why i
would make that
concession so i'm trying to ask if
that's the only hold up
and
i haven't i haven't got an explanation
on that
it it also may create some some problems
for some other members of the committee
if we do take it out so maybe that's uh
i have the person to my right shaking
their head one way or another so
representative boardney
thank you mr chair uh yeah mr ward um
under current law
are all these crimes
uh
could be considered uh serious uh
[Music]
safety to the public and themselves
and can that not be interpreted to be
required
uh to have be detained
i guess i'm i'm not sure and i apologize
that i follow the question um i mean
they're
they're certainly a list of serious
crimes um uh under the law would they be
considered serious crimes i the law
doesn't define serious crimes so i don't
know that i
the the term serious crime so again
sorry i apologize i don't know that i
follow the question basically crimes
that would be uh endangered the public
are themselves that is uh
how the current law
is worded
and domestic violence and stalking
wouldn't they not could be considered a
uh uh
a danger to uh others
certainly
and wouldn't that not be uh
uh
a reason to uh be uh detained until
would they get
in front of a judge yeah
if the question is whether or not it
makes sense to include those crimes in
the in the in the list of the other
crimes that exist here
it certainly does based on the dangers
that can be opposed to individuals based
on domestic violence and stalking crimes
so the question is
do this list of crimes do they actually
enhance the law are are they a
restatement of present law because uh
current law
ready requires that if a person is a
danger to the public
are dangerous in themselves
that they may be detained
before until they are uh and get a
hearing in front of the judge
there are certain circumstances again
under under current laws i think has
been discussed where individuals can be
detained yes
all right thank you
representative marston
thank you mr chairman
my question
to the chair and to the uh
uh mr marston if you don't mind but um
i'm gonna recognize representative bert
to ask a question to the witness as well
while he's sitting there
thank you mr chairman um thank you for
taking my question uh to follow up
on representative bordnay's uh
question
so if somebody commits one of these
crimes
under current law today
they could be held
but they're being released
for whatever reason but they could be
held
correct
follow-up yeah when you say hell are you
referring held
in pre-trial detention or held awaiting
a
bail hearing before a judge
they could be held you know to see a
judge
someone as i think has been described
during the testimony about this bill is
oftentimes when that first visit is with
the bail commissioner um
they are not held if your question is
could they be held sure they they could
be
you know so so manchester where most of
this problem is
you know they could
they could hold these people
that are on this list in the amendment
currently but they they are not holding
them
they can be under the current bill um
depending on again the factual
circumstances of the case a judge can
order someone detained yes
all right thank you
did anyone else have a question for all
right representative representative
calmly thank you mr chairman and thank
you for taking the question can you
describe
um
not what can happen but what does
typically happen in cases
in which someone is charged with crimes
included on this list that i think we
all agree are serious is that individual
typically released after seeing a bail
commissioner is that the is that what
happens more often than not in the state
so
you know the cases my office deals with
the cases i prosecute are
for the most part murder cases first and
second degree murder cases so you know
my experience is not
presently and i've again have practiced
it as a county attorney as well
but presently with
these crimes so i would i would hesitate
to venture a guess with respect to that
and would refer you back to the
testimony you've heard from law
enforcement officers when i've been here
in prior situations
or prior hearings excuse me um
and there's been testimony on this bill
and certainly
the testimony i've heard i can tell you
has been consistent with with your
statement
thank you and if i may ask a quick
follow-up you're so recognized thank you
can you remind me does your office have
a position on
uh the broader 294 not necessarily the
amendments but is your office in support
of the concept of
sb294
yes uh yes um and i and i think the last
time when i testified here said we were
we were generally in support of this
this bill and we had provided
um feedback on on technical corrections
that are uh encompassed within
representative abbess's
amendment here most specifically the new
language to lines one and two of page
two thank you
representative welch
thank you mr chairman uh on the news
this morning there was uh
a report about chief maloney in
greenland not manchester who was killed
responding to a domestic violence
incident
that's why i think that should stay in
the bill
and i'll support it
and i know that my friend from goffstown
keeps mentioning manchester manchester
manchester
but this this is a problem
throughout the entire state
now
some communities have a more a higher
population
perhaps the frequency of when this would
apply mate
play an effect on different communities
but
domestic violence isn't a manchester
problem
it's a statewide problem
so i i think i understand the point that
you're making that you keep saying
manchester i i have i don't i'm not
clear that anyone
from
i know there was a police officer in
manchester that spoke here but
we've had witnesses from all
different different parts of the state
not just manchester in support of this
you may respond thank you
uh i wasn't referring to domestic
violence
uh what i was referring to is that this
is a manchester problem
uh there is other problems throughout
the state absolutely this there's
issues out there
um
but these bills are being brought
forward especially uh representative
ross berry's bill it was brought forward
because of manchester
you know there's no secret i mean we can
say what we want but you know but you
know yes dover has problems rock chester
has problems
um but the majority of it is in
manchester and what my comment to the
attorney general was
had nothing to do with domestic violence
it was the bill itself
representative marston
thank you mr chairman
my question to you because your this
amendment is yours does this replace the
whole bill
it it is
from it is a replacement of what was
the original bill of 294.
it replaces the 290 some of it's similar
but
in in in an effort to follow along and
reference pages and line numbers
without doing the complete replacement
it
it was very difficult to navigate
between the two documents that's why i
requested this way
okay thank you
represent testimony
thank you uh
i know this is
appears to be a manchester problem
manchester has a hundred and so many
thousand people
you know i live in a city
of 8 000 we have exactly the same
problem that's described here so it's
not just manchester
uh you know we have the same nuts
running the streets
representative connolly
thank you mr chairman and not to hijack
this but um there is another amendment
that's coming um
so i'll i'll be the first to say that i
support the amendment you drafted
there is another
option depending on what happens with
that that does a few important things
that i just want to outline
it just strips the
bill the amendment down to the first
section
so it's only about making sure people
accused of quote-unquote serious crimes
have to go before a judge who would then
determine bail
so
there's there's different bites at this
apple uh and it and it delays the start
date until the start of the next fiscal
year we've heard a ton of
concern about
how do we pay for this this two million
dollars um
not sure
i think we could figure that out but
that gets rid of this concern
um so
uh i do support the amendment i think
it's important but um there are other
options that that could be considered
and i hope that
um that's known and that amendment isn't
done yet for reasons that are out of my
control but it is coming
in our our friends from the court is
here
and he uh
unfortunately has to often say the same
thing he often discusses the effective
date in a lot of bills and
a lot of times we should try to do our
best to whether they support a bill or
not
the effective date's important my
understanding was
it although without supporting the rest
of the building it was preferred to have
the effective date on the first january
first of the the count of a calendar
year
so by putting it out in well july 1st or
whatever would that be a problem for the
court
um with regard to the effective date um
july 1 is the sort of minimum effective
date bump um that's the one that's set
in the statutory in the statute
as representative conley said if we can
you know our issue
in our concern about this bill has
always been one of fiscal impact
especially on the circuit court
and as representative conley said if we
moved the effective date till july 1
when after we've gone through the budget
cycle we will then have in you know
a process by which we will have
determined the budget hopefully
incorporated the budgetary needs that we
would see
as a result of this bill and that would
be
in place by the time this became
effective yes there would be transition
but at least we would know where we are
relative to the budgetary impacts
so we do support if if there is a an
amendment that would move the effective
date to july one as opposed to january
one
that does accomplish the the need that
from our perspective of being able to
then have the budget
conversation with with relevant
committees
does any of the members have any comment
on or opinion on the effective date is
that a hold up for anyone i guess that's
the other
i think i
i think what what's being you're saying
makes sense representative conley and
and i understand the comments from
um richard had
i guess my only concern is that's over a
year from now i i understand that's how
the budget system works that's that's
how it plays out but to put this in into
place i mean if there are vacancies
in the court right now whether this
passes or not i would still support
filling those vacancies
i don't see i don't i and please correct
if i'm saying anything that's that's not
accurate if there's a if there's five
six vacancies in the circuit court
we should i would support filling those
with web you know past regardless of
this bill amendment all that so
i guess for me
as i put it as a hold up i'm not sure
we should delay it any longer than we
have to but it's just my opinion may i
so i i agree it is strange to legislate
something a year out um
so
one follow-up to that is this already
wouldn't take effect until the first of
the year so there already is a pretty
long lead-in
um
and we've heard
uh
testimony or we've heard comments from
people who will vote on this that the
cost of implementing such a program is a
hold up for them
um
i support this concept and i want to get
it through particularly the first part
and i don't want to see
this whole thing blow up
because of little things like that and
if we're talking about paying for it and
that being a hold up let's get that out
of the equation get it implemented
and
and start it a little later and
hopefully in the meantime judges who i
mean we've heard repeatedly that the
current law already lets people do lets
judges do what the bill would do
maybe they'll read the writing on the
wall and start enforcing the law a
little bit better
so if i can just ask
this is open for anyone on the committee
is
the effective date whether it's january
1st or
i'll just say july 1st of 2023
is that a hold up for anyone uh
representative espitia well i wanted to
comment and say i think you know if we
wait if we were to wait till next
session
then you would be delaying it even
further out you know we wouldn't be able
to put in a system by june 20 if we put
a new lsr in and have to go through the
whole legislative process we would have
that would probably be pushed out to
um at the soonest so you know by us
not doing this now it's gonna and
because it's gonna take you know it's
gonna take too long you're inevitably
just making it prolonging the process
and then we'll have to wait another year
and start the whole set like the whole
process all over again so
um i think the effective date of june
2023 would would just help us move along
and actually try to get something in
place because we're hearing that one of
the issues is that it's just we're just
seeing bottlenecks and being our be
people are being you know
there's just so much confusion in the
system so and people are being held and
you know so i think this would be this
would be helpful
representative bourdain
it's not a bad strategy
representative burt
uh it's nothing to do with what we're
talking about i do have a question from
uh richard head if i could mr head
i'm
okay you may ask that's the question
thank you
again
what's a red flag to this bill to me one
of them
is that the lba does not ask for a
fiscal note on it but you said it was
similar it could be similar to senate
bill 92 which i believe was about two
million dollars
if i could just talk to that we did have
the conversation with the lba
and they have now issued a fiscal note
that does incorporate our fiscal note so
um in response to the hearing
um
uh we did have the i did have a
conversation with mike hoffman
they just simply missed that that there
was an impact on us i gave them a
proposed worksheet and that's now been
uh incorporated my understanding was
that had been circulated to the
committee but
apparently not no it is essentially the
the same fiscal impact that you saw in
in
two million exactly yeah it has been
emailed to the committee
in respect to the fiscal note
i know we've all heard this we've heard
all the committees say it
the policy
the issue of the fiscal and that is that
is for
finance so if this were to pass
my understanding that this this bill
would then have to go through the
finance committee where that would be
discussed
now
do i does that mean you completely
ignore any type of fiscal impact i think
that that's
not this i'm not saying to do that but
i understand that the the fiscal impact
will have its own
its own its own argument on on its own
merits
well if i could finish yes yes thank you
in what is a magistrate system i
understand it's around a million dollars
so could we take this bill turn this
into a magistrate system
june 1st or whatever that date is
bouncing around get this rolling and
hopefully in six months after june first
uh you know we have something in place
that would work
so we've at least very preliminarily
discussed internally probably having 12
magistrates
that would work statewide the bail would
be a an electronic
bail conversation with with local police
so be telephonic or video
our estimate again preliminary would be
roughly a million dollars if that was
the system one of the things we've
talked about since i ran those numbers
is potentially having a per diem
um system where some of the current
where we would we would essentially have
a
a potential transition period also that
we would do a per diem
with some of the bail commissioners that
that would then become under our control
as employees
and and sort of transition that way
but
roughly if we were just talking the
magistrates and we had 12 it would be
initial calculations around a million
that's correct yeah and just one final
question if i can yeah thank you
um i'm not sure when that email was sent
if it was sent while we're here uh would
you think that
yesterday i think okay i missed it then
you only get about 500 emails yes
uh that two million that you speak of in
senate bill 294
does that include the county cost of the
flood of people possibly that is going
to end up in the hillsborough county
corrections you know for three to four
days whatever it is or up to 36 hours no
we explicitly uh identified that as
something we were not um including in
our cost estimate the same with public
defenders and the the additional cost on
public defenders if there is any all
right thank you
and
and in respect to a
magistrate system
having that the policy of having
magistrates as opposed to bail
commissioners that's one policy that
then the procedure for bail is its own
separate policy so what we're talking
about now is the procedure for bail
all right that so simply having a
magistrate system doesn't necessarily
i would say resolve our
differences
here
it's just it's replacing the concept of
one the other one issue that it would
resolve
i i the only issue i think it really
does resolve is
the issues of the weekend some people
have some
objection that a person can be held for
an extended period of time because
because the time period excludes
weekends and holidays if you were to
have a magistrate system
it would not be a tremendous burden to
have those
them operate on the weekend as well
but that problem the issues of the
weekends and holidays is
a problem under existing law as well
so
we we face that now whether this bill
passes or not
that weekend holidays and if you notice
uh at least when i've done a lot of the
amendments i've been rather than have 72
hours then excluding weeks and holidays
i've been kind of
moving that down to 24 to 36
and that's because i i i
have an issue kind of with the weekend
issue problem as well but
that's how the system is we can't we
can't fix that in one day mr chairman if
i could just
to make sure i understood what the
concept would be that we've been
discussing in the magistrates is who
would replace bail commissioners so the
magistrates would take over the bail
duties
along with with judges also doing some
of it the magistrates would be available
24 7 weekends holidays nights
so so just to make sure that i
understood your comment it it would
replace bail commissioners and be a 24 7
process
and if i just may ask a question
we did have another
sessions scheduled for senate bill 292
that was scheduled for 11 30. is there
any members of the public present
that
for that
bill
all right well
we'll keep we'll keep going with what
we're doing
representative ray newman thank you mr
chair
in previous testimony before this here
in this particular one right here today
you mentioned the impact that of 2800
and x number of cases would cause
at that time i was under the impression
that bail commissioners only saw only
operated on off hours of the court
so i called nashua i know we don't want
to do individual places but this is all
i could do today
we called
i called the national police department
to ask them to run me through the
process
we get to the very end
they said they use bail commissioners
and i said
so when do they see a judge well in
nashua they they use bail commissioners
almost exclusively
so with that
that new knowledge is that does that
affect
the cost it would have on the court
um if we if we all of a sudden
with this bill could not use bail
commissioners again would that affect
whatever you that your previous
testimony
i truly i may be misunderstanding the
question and i apologize if i am the the
what we had looked at were
um
everything under the list of crimes so
we we we're still not talking about the
the second and third arrest provisions
of the of the bill but just in the first
section with the list of crimes
we identified how many of those
that are currently being arrested that
have not resulted in a detention hearing
so essentially
which ones are currently going through
bail commissioners and which ones are
currently going to a to a judge for a
bail decision and we had identified and
i'm not gonna get the number exactly but
roughly three thousand so we identified
that as being
within just that first section of the
bill
the number of now
of of
previously previous uh or current system
that do not have detention bail hearings
that would now be brought before a court
and have a detention hearing
and based on that based on that
identified the number of additional
hearings that would be held in
circuit or superior court
follow-up mr
recognized for a follow-up and i'm
i'm just trying to make sure i
understand your calculations i since
i've learned and went through the list
and
and found that there were not any uh
misdemeanor b offenses in any of those
laws
but there are as
jeff ward mentioned there are some
misdemeanor a's those are circuit court
um processes
thank you
if i may inquire with the question so
the exact number i believe was just
under twenty it was around twenty eight
twenty twenty nine hundred it said would
just say twenty nine hundred
if if there's uh uh just assume that
there's a hundred and four days that are
weekends we're going on a limb there
and then we have let's just say 20
recognized holidays
i haven't done the math that either so
we look
my math it came to us
about 11.8 hearings per day throughout
the entire state now i understand the
majority of those may be in i think was
it
rochester concord
manchester and nashua
we don't know which percentage the exact
amount that goes into those but we're
talking about
let's apparently less than 12 hearings a
day on average
if we distribute it throughout the state
they're both 5.8 minutes per hearing on
average
that's the time it would take for these
bail hearings to be performed
so to to if we can just sort of follow
up on that what we had identified was
roughly within the system we would have
to incorporate i don't have the note
right in front of me about six and a
half weeks of hearing time that would
have to be brought into the system
the primary the majority of those are in
the four courts you mentioned if we're
only talking about judge time and we're
only talking about section one
as opposed to also incorporating in
the um the three the the sections of the
bill that deal with
um
third arrests for for misdemeanors and
felonies sort of adding on additional
number
which is which is
an unknown number we have the more just
concrete numbers on the on the first
section
um and then we add on top of that
the
far more than 5.8 minutes per case that
that staff have to manage
and i talked about that in in my
testimony last week and i won't repeat
it but it is
a significant staff drain
um
not trained staff time management issue
relative to each of these hearings which
would be coming in without having gone
through
the bail commissioner and the paperwork
that the bail commissioner does you
heard one of them talk about it takes
them two hours you know where what we're
doing is transferring a lot of that work
into the staff at each court
um
and and that is a significant burden far
more than 5.8 minutes per
if i can inquire but if a person even if
they're arrested today they brought and
they go before a bail commissioner the
court still has to have a case file and
have to dock at that and and create a
file i mean don't they not so i guess
what's the the only real extra step for
the court is
having that the hearing at in front of
the judge which
i mean quite often there's normally a
hearing already scheduled for other
arraignments and it's going to be added
on to an existing
yes schedule i disagree with with that
pretty strongly
what what the bail commissioner one does
is puts together all the initial orders
paperwork and that then comes to the
clerk as opposed to the clerk creating
it
and then as i had mentioned in my
testimony that clerk
is responsible for coordinating with the
county jails for each of those hearings
whether it be by video and as i
mentioned in my my testimony
what we have largely done in a number of
of counties is used up all of the video
time available in a jail so instead
staff is coordinating with
county sheriffs and the jails to arrange
for a transport at the right time and
place
uh in the in the courthouse
and then has to manage all essentially
from scratch all the paperwork that the
bail commissioner would have uh put
together in court
so i pretty strongly disagree with it's
it's just a judge time it's actually a
far greater burden on staff probably
than the judge
thank you for clarifying that
representative testament than
representative calling
thanks so thanks for taking my question
chairman i apologize can i just ask
karen gorm is with me today she has
greater knowledge about a lot of these
details and if she can join me that
would be helpful of course thank you
that's why there's two seats there i
know that's i
she's probably saying he said so many
things i saw her shaking her head and
i'm i'm just saying i'm sorry
i'm glad she's not sitting next to you
now
you saw me
in a polite manner of course
i
have a question i you you gave testimony
and maybe i didn't understand it
one of the real issues that were
we have these bills or this bill is
because a lot of people are released out
on the streets
uh again and again
and
you know the intent of
possibly having a magistrate there
would be and because
he has some judge capabilities
are we doing anything that's really
going to keep
us from releasing this if we don't
pass this bill as is it has a list of
you got to look at these
and and look at these seriously with a
judge i mean
i i i i got the impression that all we
did was replace the bail folks with
magistrates
and we got the same old
happening again
if i may respond
good morning my name is karen gorham i'm
the superior court administrator um and
i have been here for this entire work
session and heard what was being talked
about if i may before i answer your
question representative just go back and
talk for a minute about incarcerated
versus non-incarcerated arraignments and
the way we handle them in superior court
so as you know most of the charges
listed in paragraph one on page two are
felony offenses there are two that could
be misdemeanors
when when a defendant is arrested on a
felony they see a bail commissioner and
as you've heard in prior testimony most
often those defendants are released that
results in a non-incarcerated
arraignment
we hold large non-incarcerated
arraignment sessions and when the public
defender and the county attorney are
there more often than not those cases
result in an agreement
and the clerk of court takes the
paperwork a judge signs off on that
without a hearing being held so it's a
it's a session
without a judge on the bench where
everyone comes into the courtroom so
we're not taking up any judge time for
those defendants who have been released
and if they show up there's usually an
agreement between the parties so for
them to stay out on bail occasionally
the prosecutor may want to have a bail
hearing in which case it would go in
front of the judge but that's fairly
rare under our current system
by taking
this list of offenses and saying they
shall be detained meaning they won't see
the bail commissioner in the first
instance resulting in an incarcerated
arraignment the process in superior
court is we hold those arraignments some
courts do them at noon others do them at
1 or 1 30. we find out in the morning
that someone has been detained overnight
and needs to be scheduled for an
arraignment
that means the county attorney has to
file the complaints in that case our
clerk's office has to get all of the
paperwork to the public defender's
office if because they usually will
appoint for incarcerated arraignments
and then schedule that hearing
currently because they're usually done
by video as a result of covid and the
pandemic
i was in a meeting yesterday with a
judge
from hills north and another one from
hills south it took them three hours
from eleven o'clock to two o'clock to
handle four arraignments because of
problems with the jail so i think we are
going to go back to transporting those
individuals to the court
when the number of incarcerated
arraignments increase the impact that
that has on the superior courts is
fairly significant in the in the um
instance of
our judges do jury trials we currently
have a backlog we are doing we're trying
to pump out as many jury trials as we
can to help get rid of that backlog
they then have to take a break excuse
the jury until sometimes two o'clock in
the afternoon so they can handle those
last-minute incarcerated arraignments so
there is an impact
and a huge difference between the
non-incarcerated and the incarcerateds
under this bill it would increase the
number of incarcerated arraignments that
we have having the resources to conduct
those hearings without interrupting
other court business is very important
from my position as the superior court
administrator
magistrates
under what what we are talking about as
would be they do
set bail in the first instance under
this law if someone shall be detained a
magistrate won't have to be contacted to
set bail because they shall be detained
but they can also handle those
arraignments
there they will be they will have the
ability to conduct the arraignments
instead of having the judges conduct
those arraignments and that is a very
very important piece
of our thought with the magistrate bill
is that they they do set the bail
and on those cases where someone is
eligible for bail
those would be court employees who are
trained on setting bail and we would
know what they were doing and who was
available to handle the bail setting
they would then still go in front of a
judge for an arraignment if it's an
incarcerated
an incarcerated arraignment the
magistrates can step in and handle those
in the middle of the day so there
there's a significant impact um
with the magistrate system
and how it coincides with the bail law
and i think richard did touch on this
you know it's not only that first
paragraph with the mandatory detentions
for 72 hours it's also the repeat
offenders and those who are currently
out on bail who may reoffend that will
also be detained increasing the number
of those incarcerated arraignments
i hope i've answered your question i
know that was very long-winded and i
apologize
remember same call me
thank you
um you did answer uh i think the
question or as i understood the question
raised by representative testerman
because i had the same question but i
can these not code could a magistrate
system coexist
uh with a system that requires
bail and still
and essentially send some people to a
magistrate to lighten the load but
require more
people accused of violent crimes to come
before an official judge
like would these exist in the way that i
think the court system wants
yes
okay and if i may follow up
recognize for a follow-up thank you i've
heard a lot about magistrate
for the last few months i've not seen a
single bill or amendment does one exist
or are we talking about a concept
uh two thirds of the way through a term
that can't necessarily get acted upon
this term
so i can speak i do have a draft i'm
happy to share with the committee
a draft bill um and i can distribute
that today if you wanted
thank you
if you
could possibly email it to
to myself i can i know i think i might
have a copy of it but if just make sure
we're done
send it out i'll have it printed out for
the members of the committee
representative harry catherine um i have
an amendment coming later and it
actually is um
the same
draft that was um presented by mr head
is it in regards to the magistrate yes
it is absolutely and and before and if
we did
now just to point this out if we were to
have a magistrate system put into place
that were to then replace
what
was senate bill 94
i would want to before we do anything
with that i would want to confirm
whether that's a germain amendment it's
it's on the issue of bail i get that but
we are completely replacing the system
of
we would essentially be repealing any
bail commissioner
law that's on the books right now so i
would want to confirm that and if it's
not ruled uh
if it's if it's deemed not jermaine all
we have to do is have a public hearing
on that
and separate and notice it so i just
i would want to confirm that before we
do even consider that
okay
question two question to the chair um
would um would be
was his name anthony over there would he
know if that's jermaine
the that is some that's that's decided
by the the speaker of the house okay
i i my only
my only other comment that i would make
is when it's a non-german amendment we
could do that with any
but by the nature of what it is it's not
your main we could do that with any
existing bill
so
my question is
if we put in a magistrate system
we still got to come up with with the
bail policy that would work with that
magistrate system and then agree on that
so
you can take the policy that's set forth
said fourth and senate bill is the
amendment to senate bill
you or you may not agree with the policy
in there but you may agree with the
magistrate system
so so there is a benefit of also having
them separate i mean if we can't even
agree on the policy here
i gave my opinion on what i i think it's
a good system i i would i am supportive
of converting to that system
but in the meantime i'm just not sure
we're going to do it
so
representative bourdain
thank you mr chair um
so are you aware that we the house has
passed a uh
bill 1476
and it deals with uh
repeat offenders
are do you if this becomes law are you
going to see an impact on the
judicial system today
so
yeah um so we did provide testimony on
that the the um
that bill
would
um
address
covers it's very broad covers felonies
class a and class b misdemeanors class a
and class b separately
and
would prohibit
pr bail
so would have a significant impact on
the on the court system
from a fiscal perspective that's correct
would it have as big as impact as this
bill would have it's actually somewhat
broader than this bill so probably uh
oh
well in some ways it's broader in this
especially when we're focused on section
one which has a list of crimes as well
it doesn't have
no
i'm sorry that's not 1476. it doesn't
have a list of uh
crimes i understand i'm sorry
i wasn't clear 294 has a list of crimes
the house bill does not covers all um
felonies class a and class b misdemeanor
so it's much broader
let me let me just clarify because
you're you're referencing hb
that
the application of that the policy in
that bill what it when it would apply is
if someone gets arrested well
out on bail
they are then
that policy
that price would simply be brought
before judge not a bail commission
that's what
that would do i know there was an
amendment to it but that's that's the
only application that would have the
list of crimes we have here
specifically has to do you don't
necessarily have to be on bail in the
nature of those crimes are as i said
before violent offenses so in that
scenario
you're not violating the conditions of
your release you could have no criminal
record at all but if you are charged
with one of those offenses listed on
page two lines one through twenty those
if you charge one of those
you would it's similar in philosophy you
would be held
before judge but they're very different
on the and the procedure and application
does that make sense there's a
difference between violating the
conditions of one's release or the
conditions of their bail and a person
not being on bill and being arrested
for the first time
does that make any sense
i guess i'm maybe i'm i don't understand
what i'm listening to
uh in 1476
we left the language for rob
detention
in the present law which is a danger to
themselves or our danger to the public
safety
uh what we did change
is the ability to
detain people for repeated crimes
that is what i am
questioning whether or not that is going
to have a major impact on the judicial
system
yeah so the answer is in terms of of
impact on the on the court system the
answer is yes um it would have a
significant fiscal impact on the on the
court system for the similar reasons
that we've been discussing
and
back to my follow-up uh if we were to
add on
this particular bill as as written today
which lists uh
major crimes that also have to be uh
in front of a george a judge before they
can be detained would that would
actually add more uh
load to the court system so just in
terms of of the bill we're talking about
today 294 page 4
lines 21
through page five line two
that's that's
has similar impacts to the house bill
and in the sense of this is the this one
in in this one it's a it's the i think
the third arrest um
so some of those impacts from the house
bill are
also in this role i understand that and
then on top of that
the the first section
is first arrest it would be a detention
hearing so that does add on top of the
either the house bill or that other
section of this senate bill that's
correct
all right thank you
representative burke do you have a
question
yes i do thank you mr chairman
uh
if the amendment for the magistrate
did pass and you know replaced uh 294
which i would support
um
how quick you ready representative
i think it's being written by uh
representative garth wright
yeah so yes yep uh so how quick would
that you know let's say if we set a date
of june
how fast could you put that together you
know you know i'm assuming you'd have to
hire staff and judges and
you know etc
so it
and karen can follow up i think the
one would be um
getting through the budget process
two would probably be within that
establishing a per diem system so we
could create a transition
and then third would be as you said the
hiring of of the
magistrates
that takes a a bit of time so
um
yeah we're probably talking in terms of
of hiring and getting them in place six
months
um at least to put to implement that
phase of it yep and a follow-up mr
chairman
representative you recognize for a
follow-up thank you
um
so if that took place you know we're
looking you know possibly january 1st uh
we'd have something in place to help
this
situation that we're having in you know
mainly manchester but also throughout
the state
um
and those people would be under the
judges control
where
is it you know i kind of if you could
correct me i'm hearing that the bales
bond men are not under
the control of the judge is that true
and this would also be cheaper if we did
it this way instead of passing 294 so i
can't imagine
um you know the fiscal
finance would say no to this
so um just one slight correction
representative bale bondsman versus bail
commissioners there's a lot of confusion
between the two the bail bondsmen
actually write the bond and provide the
insurance i apologize yep no which is a
separate issue because we have very few
in our state now after bail reform in a
few years ago there was no business so
they've left the state hopefully they'll
come back if we build it they will come
hopefully the bail commissioners are
are responsible to the chief justice of
the superior court and the
administrative judge of the circuit
court
they're trained and hired the local
judges do not have any control over the
bail commissioners the bail
commissioners make their own independent
assessments and i believe um richard has
spoken in the past about some of the
issues that we've had with bail
commissioners and given examples because
they're not court employees
and we are not in control of when they
go out to which department and and take
take care of the bail
so no they are not responsible to the
judges in the individual
whereas to put the flip side of that as
as magistrates they would be court
employees they would be directly
responsible to the courts and
uh and subject to discipline within the
court system if appropriate all right
thank you and and it's a cheaper cost
and in terms of of the overall budgetary
impact correct yeah thank you
so
if if i just may inquire with the
committee here it's it's a couple
minutes past 12 o'clock
we have members of the public here
i don't have a problem working through
lunch but
i know not everyone agrees
agrees with me on that so
is do any members want i'm gonna it's
gonna be short i know some people are
sensitive about that too but
we can break for a half hour
is there any members of the public here
that are on a time schedule that
well mr chairman how much more time are
we going to pound on this
i mean i think most of us have our minds
made up where we want to be
i'm confident that you do
correct
work
yes i like i like cheap
well could there there's other members
of the of the public present today that
are here to offer some comments as well
could i ask one quick question i mean
i'm asking a question about does the
committee want to get lunch
ed but you will if the answer is no then
the answer is no
i'm just asking
point of order point of order
representative newman you're recognized
for your point of order please state
your point of order my point of order is
that while you are polling people for
lunch you've allowed other
members to ask questions without even
seeking recognition
and i've been seeking recognition and
have been not been recognized so i have
not said anything all right i'm going to
rule on your point of order it's it's
within my understanding it's within the
discretion that you're here to recognize
someone to ask a question that's my
ruling if you don't like my um exercise
my discretion you can challenge the
ruling of the chair back to the
conversation about lunch
all right the committee will be in
recess to
12 35.
i just i just asked him that question
um
oh
this time we'll now reopen the work
session on senate bill
294.
all right before we we get into any
other topics on
e
there's a couple amendments now floating
around
are there any other questions i know
representative o'hare you had a
hand up
no
what's the new when you have a question
thank you mr chairman i was just
wondering if i could
address a question to the people who
were
testifying earlier and it probably
shouldn't take any longer than 30
seconds to ask the question just ask the
question
thank you
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um
we're talking about future things so i
like to put that aside and ask a
question about this bill
effectively for the number of crimes
that are are listed
takes away the ability of using a bail
commissioner
just with that if we if we were to pass
the bill and that still remained that
you could not use a bail commissioner
would it have a financial impact or on
on the court system
so um i if i understand so essentially
we would be
removing the bail commissioners from the
process and putting it into the courts
so so
so essentially decreasing the load on
bail commissioners
and increasing the load on on the court
so yes
thank you
representative manager putin
thank you mr chair
um
a quick question in terms of the
transition
knowing what we have currently with the
workforce and all that how quickly the
transition from bail to
magistrate can happen and what would be
the
backlog if
i if i i'm just gonna and and this is
not directed at this representative i
we discussed that we flowed
the idea of having a magistrate system
the amendment right now does not address
a magistrate system
so i i don't think we need to get into
any more detail about
or questions or discussion on having a
magistrate system
so can i rephrase it and say are we
entertaining a hybrid in a transition
the amendment that's i've seen this far
doesn't actually would not have a
magistrate
procedure in there
and i mean this is the last time i'm
going to reference this
if you had a magistrate system there
still needs to be a bail procedure
in place
so
we're talking about the policy of the
procedure that's what senate bill 294 is
as well as the the amendment
that's what it would
cover so i guess my question is
in regards to the amendment
do any members have any questions about
anything that's in that bill
right now
[Laughter]
h
the one that we've been talking about
since 10 o'clock
is there any questions about that
amendment as direct written
okay so you know okay now i understand
if
buzz shearer is here does any members
have any questions that they would wish
to direct specifically to buzz
share about any of the material in here
we're not asking i'm not asking for
testimony i'm just asking is there any
questions anyone has about anything
representative
track
i i just turned all the mics off let's
try turning them back on
[Laughter]
that's nice i like that thank you um
uh thank you for coming
there's a cost of two million dollars
here
are there
cheaper alternatives
that we could apply
or go to
that would get a better result
and just remind everyone the issue of
the fiscal impact is for is a policy
that's considered by the finance
committee
see which this bill i would
imagine would find its way there
okay i could reword it
um
okay i'll reword it
currently
we're releasing people that
probably shouldn't be released
the bail the uh uh who's releasing them
now it's uh because i want to make sure
bill commissioner commitment okay i want
to make sure i get the right words so
the bail commissioners are releasing
people that probably shouldn't be
released
is there other alternatives
instead of just this bill that would
achieve
a better result
yes
um
the fundamental
struggle that's been going on about
bill reform
is a dissatisfaction
amongst many stakeholders
about the performance of bail
commissioners
it has been erratic around
the state
some are very good
some are less than very good
the court system has made efforts to
improve their training
but i think
everyone recognizes that that has been
very difficult and probably hasn't
worked partly because the court they're
not technically employees of the court
system
so um so
people are getting released that the
police don't think should be released
and people are getting held that
uh
defense lawyers don't think should be
held
uh and it it is really
at the core of the the issues that have
bothered
many stakeholders
about bail reform
um
if one were to
regularize
who is an individual is seeing for the
first time
um when when they're arrested
um and that person was available or some
version of that person was available 24
7.
that may well take care of many of the
problems
that many stakeholders are complaining
about
as to bail reform
because
uh they will be in they would be
employees of the court system there
would be you know they could be held to
task
uh if they were
going rogue so to speak in the nature of
their rulings
there would be an ability for
individuals
be it police lawyers citizens to
complain directly to the court system
about their performance there would be a
regular evaluation process
it would improve
that
weakness in the system that pressure
point in the system at the front end of
the system substantially and you know
i've read the
the magistrate proposal that the court
system has been working on for at least
a year and vetting and uh it would have
that effect and you know practically
speaking
the right way to go about this process
if one looks at the big picture
i think everyone agrees the right way to
go about this process
is to is to
adopt a magistrate system
see if it cures
most of the problems that we're having
now with bail reform
and if it isn't then come back with
bills such as this one or uh you know
other bills once we know
what the problem is now that we've
plugged that weakness now that we've
developed made that weakness a strength
that's the best way to do things um
and um i'm
you know i i think i've made clear to
everyone i i that's
i'm a strong advocate of that you know i
can see
i can see there's still being a need for
some bail reform in some reform of the
bell reform statute in certain
circumstances after we have magistrates
in place and
you know
i would be much more comfortable
supporting that because i would know
that we have grown ourselves out of that
weakness
but until we do that
we you know we don't know
we don't know how many people
who are held on domestic violence
charges end up being acquitted or end up
having their charges
dropped we don't know
and i think uh to be
probably too blunt about it there are
very serious domestic violence cases and
there are other domestic violence cases
that are overcharged
there are very serious stalking cases
and there are
other very serious stalking cases
and other stalking cases that are
overcharged and
by
what this bill does is it takes
the discretion at the front end it takes
much not all but much of this discretion
away from
a
the judge
as to sorting out the serious domestic
violence cases the serious stalking
cases
and the overcharged stalking or domestic
violence cases and and that's my
difficulty uh with this bill it uses
for those misdemeanors it uses a
categorical approach
uh too quickly
i
have no difficulty i have less
difficulty
uh with the non-misdemeanor portions of
this bill um
but the short answer is yes
if we were to put in place a magistrate
system
and then look at what we need to do
about bail reform because we'll have
better data we'll have more reliable
stakeholder in the uh in the court
system in that regard not that the the
bail commissioner system is the fault of
the court system at this point uh then
we'll be in all of us will be in a much
better position to make high quality
decisions
yeah my mic's oh it is working
thank you mr chair
in the uh situation that you were just
describing in your testimony
where you were talking about some system
that would be would be um able to
probably
solve some of these problems
in the period between now and if we
don't pass this if we pass this bill
until that happens
is there a form of employment that
perhaps a contract or some other legal
form of employment
that would make could make that
what is now a bail commissioner more
accountable to the account to the court
where they might receive
better training
i would defer to the representatives
from the court system to for to give a
firm answer of that
my belief is we already have that system
that's what bail commissioners are
and and um
um i you know i i will i will be as
blunt as i tend always to be
i think we should get the
magistrate system in place now as soon
as possible
uh to to make it happen you know if some
mechanism were used to make that happen
this session we could be up and running
with the the magistrate system uh by
january 1st of of this coming year um
and uh
so
i don't think there's a there's any
substitute for the bail commissioner
system that gets us much closer to the
magistrate system in the interim
follow-up
and does
i i'm not sure that i agree that the
contractors right now um i'm just
thinking that some kind of
my question was meant to ask
some kind of system where they are paid
by the state and they are responsible
more responsible to the state
so i just want to clarify that i don't
know whether you yeah um
i don't think so
you know i
that would probably need statutory
authorization i mean the bail
commissioners that are statutorily
authorized and in fact they have all the
powers of a judge in setting bail by
statute
explicitly
but they're paid
technically whether they're contractors
or not they're paid like contractors
they're paid on a case-by-case basis
thank you
thank you chair
thank you for taking my question i won't
ask you the obvious question whether you
think this bill is necessary at all
but you mentioned just a few minutes ago
that if we incorporated this new
judicial system that we would have
better data
um
how would we get more data about what
is happening
um
since i'm a law professor i get to get
to give at least two answers
answer number one
is
technically
data is available
in a manual count way
i
could get a list of all the
i think i could get a list of all the
domestic violence cases by case number
from the court system
yeah so
i could get it either from the court
system by case number or from the public
defender system
then i could go to the court service
that allows you to give them a name and
a case number and you can get the case
summary from them
and you can look at the one-page case
summary about all the different things
that happened in the case
but that is a to
to do that and look at enough cases that
your data would be reliable at all is is
just uh not possible um so no the data
is not available in any real sense
although in that way i just described
technically it is
um you know the
we
we could certainly make a part of
the magistrate
system
that
data be kept of the results of the
magistrate court ruling
in each case
um
that would be something of an add-on but
that could be something that we we would
do
i think would make sense doing as a part
of a magistrate court system because
it would inform us going forward about
whether we need bail form or not whether
you know let's assume let's assume uh as
amended the amendment for 294 passes
fails let's assume it fails
we would be able to come back and say
look here's what's happening too many
people charged with serious domestic
domestic violence cases that are getting
eventually getting convicted are getting
out on bail or are going on and
committing more to domestic violence
crimes you know we we would have
a better shot at getting that data to
sort out whether we really need to
include domestic violence or stalking on
this list the misdemeanors on on the
list and and the amendment um
so it's a kind of a long-winded answer
but it's
there's as you can tell there's
uncertainty in at a number of levels
uh it's still one i'm still uncertain
about the data maybe i have to talk to
the judicial system to see what
is actually available yeah eventually
nothing is available
i was going to but i think i'm done
thank you
thank you mr chairman thanks for taking
my question you stated in your testimony
earlier that a clerk magistrate system
could be up and running by the first of
january
that's my understanding based on uh uh
uh the court representative's testimony
okay um follow-up please
have a point order
not talking january 2023 i'm talking
january 2024 got it
okay thank you follow up
the chair has ruled that uh talking
about the magistrate is
not in this discussion of the amendment
294 and we're once again getting off
track
and
all the questions are going referring
back to the magistrate and i would like
to deal with this
what's in front of us because the
magistrate's not in front of us and i
don't have any idea what we're talking
about
i can't i'm shocked to hear that that
happened while i wasn't in the room
all right
so
i i
i've said i wanted to say it again
the
we're not going to discuss the
policy of a magistrate system
any further it's not
in my opinion it's not
it's not part of this amendment
and and that's that
so
it's not referenced in there that's the
that's a separate policy so if we're
going to be discussing that any further
i'm just going to deem it out of order
not relevant to what we're talking about
we could have
a
ad hoc hearing where we can just
schedule a hearing where we all meet and
we just discuss
the policy of a magistrate system and
i'm willing to do schedule that hearing
it has to be noticed but i would be i
would entertain that and i would hope
we have full attendance if we did
well we're still in the work session
so
representative schultz do you have a
question for
do you i am hearing
um thank you for taking my question uh
as a concord rep i recently overheard
that our
bail commissioner
position is unfilled i don't remember i
believe that's at the county level
um
do you know how many open
uh how many vacancies there are maybe
that's a better question for someone
else but it it i do not and that is a
better better uh uh mr head may well
have the uh answer to that question i i
know there are unfilled bail
commissioner positions
representative bert you're recognized
uh this is for the chairman a question
to the chairman
uh the 12 years i've been here
a
full committee work session
is not based on one amendment that the
chairman put it in
it is based on
you know open discussion
to see what is the best result
um again you know i've been here 12
years been on many work committee
sessions and
we talk about a lot of stuff we talk
about the finances we talk about
you know stuff that is not in this
committee
so i guess i'm just confused why we're
just
uh restricted to talk about your
amendment
when
that's not been the case in the last 12
years but the other is
so you want me to answer that question
you have another question yep no i'll if
you want to answer my understanding is
all that is within the discretion of the
chair if someone did not agree with the
ruling of the chair they were they had
the opportunity to challenge the ruling
of the chair
and at this time i i considering there
was no challenge made i assume
that they they have since waived that
and i think that in respect to the
money in reference to the
fiscal impact
i want to thank the members of the court
for providing that to us it's been well
stated already we're not going to get
any more information on we already know
what the fiscal impact
is projected to be it's already there to
continue to keep talking about the
fiscal impact
over and over again
is even though it's outside the purview
of this committee it's actually still
also
repetitive
that's why i made that decision and in
respect to the magistrate system
if this if people want to talk about a
different type of amendment
i'm sp all we've been talking about was
specifically
uh 1486
there's
representative colony referenced another
one but again the we're not even sure
the magistrate amendment would be ruled
germain we would i would
think that we would need to clarify that
so we're not going to talk about the
magistrate
system right now
and i wouldn't be inclined to
consider
having a non-german hearing
for a magistrate system
in respect to senate bill 294. so when i
say there's no need to talk about him
respect 294 because as the chair of the
committee i have the discretion
to consider having that non-germane
hearing
and i'm not going to do that
so that's why talking about any further
in respect to 294 would
not be a good use of our time
any other questions of
of
mr well i got one last question if i may
is that a question for the uh for the
chair
you may make another parliamentary
inquiry all right
i'm not exactly sure when we started
this um
now 10 o'clock so we're
so we're approaching what three three
and a half hours um
you know and we're just pounding on the
same issues in the in the bill on the
amendment
uh
you know i think we all know where we're
going to vote
i'm trying to get there i need to close
the work session in order to have an
executive session all right then i'd be
uh and i agree it's been rather
repetitive so i think we're ready to
rock and roll yes thank you
do you have a question the chair of the
question because
oh okay so let me just do this
thank you thank you professor shear for
your
could could i correct one statement that
was made earlier it's a minor point but
it's important important to me it's a
very take me 10 seconds
i'll give you 15 seconds
thank you for your graciousness
um
it was said earlier that the chief
maloney the death of chief maloney in
greenland was a domestic violence case
it was not it was a drug raid that went
bad
and that's what it was about
thank you
at this time we will now close the
work session on
it can be this any questions for me it
can be discussed
representative are you recognized for
your question
thank you mr chair
um
there is an amendment that i would like
for
the committee to review or see um i did
send it to everyone
um
because i think it's important to this
session as well
that we're in
we
what amendment is that it's harriet gets
right
um
22 15 10 h and does that involve a
magistrate system yes it does okay
i've already explained
my position on that i wouldn't recognize
anyone to even offer an amendment on a
magistrate system in respect to 294.
i think
i've i'm not going to repeat that
so
at this time we will now close the work
session on senate bill 294.
at this time we will now open the
executive session on senate bill 294
before i recognize anyone for a
motion or an amendment i do have one
question
of the committee
there is another one that's it's
numbered 1509 it's i virtually identical
to what 1486 is the only difference is
if you go to page 4
lines 21
236 onto the next page uh page five
lines one and two
that's roman numeral eight
roman numeral eight
the the policy under the existing law
was addressed by house bill
1476 and it's passed the house and is
currently in
the senate
what i'm asking what the thought was
was the policy set forth
under that particular paragraph
we let that be decided under
the house bill in the senate so
what this amendment would do 1509 all it
would do is leave the language under
roman numeral eight identical to what
the existing law is today
and i'm just asking if there's any
any preference
i like the i like the language in
1486 better but at the same time
that is a policy that the house passed
already and perhaps we not we don't
revisit that with this bill
is there anyone that has any just to
show hands is anyone against
changing it or they want to leave it the
same
i'm just telling you i'm i'm not going
to bother handing it out if it if it's
irrelevant but i can hand it out right
now it's the same i'm just trying not to
drown people in paperwork
could i ask a question of the chair just
to clarify what you said and i'm looking
at section 8 i just wanted to make sure
i understand what you said when we at
the appropriate time i just want to call
you you may ask the question
okay so
as i understand it it will leave the law
it will leave section 8
as it is described in this amendment
and
the all of the bold the shells and the
the bold which is added language
in the
the language that is lined through
which is deleted language
that will go back to the original
original state of section 8 in the law
is that correct
whatever the existing law it is today
that's why
it it will not be impacted by
amendment number 1509 that was addressed
by hp 1476.
is this are we passing around
well no there's no there's been no
amendment introduced i'm just asking
there was some thought of
that
that was single policy being discussed
so i'm just asking if there's a
preference of the committee
1509 would leave roman numeral eight the
exact same as it is under existing law
which is being addressed by hp 1476. so
i'm just asking if there's a preference
of it doesn't mean to support the bill
i'm just wondering if there's any
opinion
representative calling mr chairman given
the
uh
bipartisan vote and the strong vote in
the house on 1476 i think we should stay
in line with that bill
although i like the language and 1486
better i i don't agree with what you i
don't disagree with what you're saying
we're gonna we're gonna have emotion i'm
gonna recognize someone to make a motion
right now
this time the chair will recognize
representative roy to make a motion
i would like to move um amendment 19.
you're being recognized to make a motion
of ought to pass yes i ought to pass
with amendment number and you wish to
offer an amendment yes
1486.
i think
i think you mean uh
2022-1509-h that's the one yes
second mr chairman
i'm trying my best
it it it and that's been seconded by
representative rhodes
so representative are you responsible
for behind it it's 1509 is that correct
that's the amendment thank you
it's
yes
h
and the only section that is different
on that is roman numeral eight which is
just
what the existing law is today which i
assume everyone is familiar with
representative roy yes
does every member of the committee have
a copy of the amendment
okay representative rory do you wish to
speak on your motion
thank you mr chairman
um
at the risk of
seeing the word um i
i do favor a
magistrate system
having said that with no
no magistrate
system before us i would like to say
that
it's going to take a long time to get
that in place it's going to require
extensive public hearings a lot of work
in the meantime there are people getting
out and people are getting hurt and i
know we've been here a while but we do
have to address this and i think that
the the amendment in front of us is a
good vehicle to do that
so until such time as we can actually
get to a better system we have to deal
with the one we have
and i think that
we need to do something now so that's
where i stand on
this representative rhodes
thank you mr chairman
so
a lot of times we hear people saying
that they wish that they had heard you
know more from a particular group of
people
or so forth and i think that it is
it is not a lack of concern that we
haven't heard from a lot of of victims
of these crimes that we continuously
talk about
it's
it's the fact of how horrendous it is
for the victims to continuously have to
come and relive their nightmare which is
nothing new
and
it's also very unfortunate that you can
have somebody come testify
in a public hearing where you're
supposed to be gathering information to
make
very educated decisions that are going
to affect the entire state to have
somebody sit and testify that is
given extreme falsehoods on the reality
of of what an exact situation is
and um
you know i i don't think that we can
less you know
dumb down if you will you know domestic
violence in any in any way and i think
that society needs to take into serious
account
the impact that these crimes have on the
victims and their families
and
the support system that these people
have
representable hearn
then then represent boy you can go next
i just got a question for the chair on
the amendment uh did we have a
discussion about maybe changing the
effective date
or was that
instead of january to either june or
july first
i believe there was a different
during the work session there was a
conversation about
having an effective date of
and represent colin was july 1st
the new fiscal year uh
there was some talk discussion about
that
i didn't i didn't get the sense that the
effective date of this was a deal
breaker
personally i i don't think that that's i
i respect what the representative from
dover had to say about that i just think
putting an effective eight over a year
away
my own my own opinion too when it comes
to trying to
properly fund the court staff
i i think if this
if this became law it's a much stronger
person more persuasive argument that the
to fill those slots not maybe you don't
want to maybe
by waiting it by waiting that long i
mean
it doesn't necessarily mean they're
going to get funded that's the other
thing that it is what it is but
i would i'd be putting over years not
something i'm really
on board with
representative manager
yeah
i don't know which question i had in
mind right now so it's kind of
i'll pass
representative ordnay
uh you told us that in amendment 1509
you changed
paragraph 8
to agree with 1476 but i read at the
line 25 page four
uh the
retained period is not more than 72
hours but my understanding what was
supposed to be 36 hours let me clarify
what i would let me clarify it so 1476
passed the house
made changes to what
on what is
roman numeral number eight paragraph
eight
what i'm saying is this is stated as the
existing wall
i didn't want to i could take what is
in senate bill
excuse me house bill 1476 you could put
it into an amendment that the issue is
that policy it hasn't passed in the
other body yet
and i figured the policy that is under
that one paragraph eight let that be
decided on its own merit since the house
where it took a position on it i didn't
want to repass that this
um i i also do the senate passed a
different version in what was the
original
draft of senate bill 294
i'm going to let that i assume
that if they
if the language that they pro that that
body prefers
they would
either a make an amendment to what is
1476.
i just figured the house took a position
on that and it's not contradicted in the
subsequent bill so leaving as the
existing law
it
it's you we can do that if they both
were to pass and become law
i would assume that
294 would need to be signed first and
that's how that would work
but it doesn't make any i just left it
as it is
uh mr chairman i uh disagree with that
uh
we know that uh whatever is the last
bill
signed is what becomes the law
so if uh
is superseded by senate bill 294
what the language in 294 would be the
law
but the only changes is going to be what
what's in the bold writing so
if
technically you don't actually i'm not
really sure it matters what order
they're signed in
but to the extent that you look at this
as you know
reasserting the existing law all would
that mean it would need to be signed
second but it's the existing law
it's not being changed
if we were to change it then it would
definitely matter which one was signed
first
so
considering the house took a position
this committee took a position on that
that was a very narrow narrow
position a narrow application so that's
why we're here now
so
i will say that i'm going to post this
amendment
and oppose the
bill as amended
and i'll also want to make a statement
that
current law
already protects people in domestic
violence situations as well as stalking
so
this is not something that we as a
committee
are ignoring this is something that is
already protected
thank you
and this time seeing no hands raised the
this is and this is uh whether to adopt
the amendment that's the that's the
question we have now but representative
burke
this is just on the amendment this is
what right now we're just trying to we
need the question is whether to adopt
amendment 1509 h all right i'll wait for
the full bill
representative newman
make sure i have that 1509 h is the
latest one i want to make sure so 1509 h
i am going to vote for
i i think that uh it's an improvement to
what's in the current one so i will vote
for that amendment and i'll uh hold my
judgment on the law itself on the bill
itself thank you
this time
we will now move the question if you are
in support of adopting amendment number
2022-1509-h
please say yay
if you're opposed please say nay the
clerk and i'll call the roll
vice chairman roy
yes
representative welch
representative bert
no
representative rhodes
yes representative greene
representative tester
no
clerk votes yes
representative genegan yes
representative pratt
no
representative marston
yes
representative harriet gathright
no representative manjuputi
no
representative o'hearn
yes
representative boardnay no
representative schultz
no
representative ray newman
yes
representative van
representative conley
yes
representative bradley no
representative espitia no
chairman abbas
that chair votes yes
eleven yays
nine nays
the amendment is adopted
the committee will be
in recess for 10 minutes
and
we're gonna we're gonna have a caucus
you're welcome to attend representative
it's never on purpose i
we will now reopen the uh executive
session
on senate bill 294
representative roy you're recognized
i would like to make a motion of ought
to pass an amendment on
as a minute as amended sb 294 with
amendment 1509
and is there there's a second that okay
so now the amendment's already been
adopted but now it's it's octopus the
motion's not allowed to pass as amended
representative newman
do you wish sp you wish to speak on the
motion of ought to pass as amended
or is it a parliamentary inquiry a
parliamentary parliamentary degree is it
an appropriate motion to
i'd like to make a motion to reconsider
the amendment i don't know
15 000 there's already a emotional
well it's a parliamentary inquiry so
it's it's and that was a
legitimate parliamentary inquiry you
need to be recognized for a motion to
reconsider
i i at this time i'm i'm not inclined to
recognize anyone for a motion to
reconsider we haven't even discussed
the question right now it's odd to pass
as amended
thank you
representative borden you wish to speak
on the motion of ought to pass as
amended
yes sure
i'm going to oppose this uh
motion
i think that current law already takes
care of what all we need to do today
um
and and to be truthful with you we have
just heard from the court system
that
uh
changes that we have proposed for hb
are
going to keep have some financial
consequences
as well as uh
hearing times and court time
and i think
before we go
about trying to add additional workflow
for the court system
we should see what those ramifications
are
so i will oppose the motion
representative thank you mr chairman
i'm opposed to this because there's a
better alternative
now on
house bill 1476 i was a co-sponsor i
voted against it
because it
was not what i thought the bill was
going to be
and now we're talking 294 so we already
passed
something similar to this so now we're
on 294 and i keep bringing it up
and the ag guy today said
these people can be put in jail
they do not have to release them so this
is not needed
we can fix it with another way
you know we're we're sent here to
concord
to do the right thing and in my eyes the
right thing is to fix this problem
so again i voted against 1490 1476 the
ross berry bill it's in the senate
they can pass it and we go pretty close
to what we have here
so what i'm looking at is
today we could be the heroes
by gutting this bill and putting in the
magistrate system
because that is really the right way to
go
yes it's you know january of 24
when it would be up and running
but i think we'll survive if we did that
because bottom line i keep coming back
to it
these criminals that keep committing
crimes can stay in jail they don't have
to let them out
now where that ball is being dropped i
don't know i'm hearing a lot of
different rumors everybody's blaming
everybody
i'm just saying that you know please
don't vote for this
this is not the way we should be going
there was other amendments that were not
allowed to be dis and they were
discussed during the three plus hour
uh subcommittee that we had or work
session but um you know they're not
talked here
and i think we should be able to talk
because you know this is important
you know we could make a huge difference
today
huge and representative bird if you just
may suspend for a moment
and this is a point of void has been
raised several times in this committee
we only can discuss the
right now the question that is
open all right which is ought to pass as
amended and the that amendment was 1509
h
and the committee we only can we only
can make a recommendation adopt one
amendment it's not like i'm when we're
in the house session where you can have
multiple floor amendments
that is not something we can do
so
although several of them were discussed
we can just procedurally speak in the
committee we cannot consider them all
pass one then pass them that's not
something we can do
so
just start explaining that before
someone raised the point of order all
right thank you well then let's go to
page two of the amendment
line six
i cannot imagine
a person that does
child sexual abuse images
under rsa um
uh
would be released from jail
i can't imagine that they're going to
release him from jail or her
um
and if you look down at the list
you know trafficking
a person i i can't imagine us
releasing somebody from jail doing that
the people that are being released from
jail
you know not strictly manchester but
that's where you know i live close to
manchester so i hear about it all the
time
they're being you know it's the uh you
know the people that are stealing from a
store is it wrong yes
but
that's true it's not even on this list
so
the people that are in here
we're not going to let out of jail
anyways
so bottom line you know we shouldn't
pass this we already passed one in uh
you know house bill 1476 so i'm gonna
you know and i was opposed to that so
i'm still a no vote and i hope i can get
some of you to join me and say no to
this because we have a better
alternative that if we stuck together
we could pass it
and make it work thank you
representative i can inquire with a
question when you say let them out of
jail are you referencing pre-trial
detention or being released
what do you mean by that
well what's happening is they're being
arrested
and then they're being released you know
and then within a couple hours
that's from what i am understanding
and anybody on these lists
you know in the amendment i i cannot
imagine that we're releasing them
you know i'd like to see somebody come
in here and say yeah i was just arrested
for uh child porn and they let me out
within an hour
i'm guessing they're not going to be
here if we ask them to show up because
i'm a thinking that they're still going
to be in jail
so in my eyes this bill is not needed
representative
i'm just trying to clarify what would
happen if you're on if you are charged
with an offense on this list
you still actually may be released
understand that that person may not
actually be held in pre-trial detention
procedurally the only thing that will
happen is
as opposed to being in front of a bail
commissioner they are being brought to a
judge with that will is where your bail
hearing would be not with the bail
commission that's the only
that's what this paragraph
on page 2 lines 1 through 20 does
if at that hearing the it the state
could ask and they would have to
demonstrate by clearing convincing
evidence that person
poses a danger to themselves to the
public in in that case the person can be
held in pre-trial detention for many
offenses that can be done already as
well
this is simply just saying if you commit
one of these offenses
you will not go in front of a bill
that's all it's saying so that doesn't
mean the person's gonna be held for an
extended period of time we're talking
the time period that
as stated here it's up to 24 to 36 hours
which is consistent with the court rules
the weekends and holidays are what they
are
they're brought in front of a judge
that's what it would that's what it
would do now whether you like that
policy you're not also the story but to
say that that
all these individuals are going to be
held in pre-trial detention that's not
necessarily
what this would do at least with that
list well may i follow up with a
clarification
all right if you look online's page uh
page two uh lines two
second-degree assault
you know that's a pretty harsh crime
the the other one is
aggravated felonious sexual assault
that's a pretty harsh crime
i'm assuming
they're going to be held for a couple
days if it's the weekend let's say they
did this on friday night they're going
to be held until monday to see a judge
monday or tuesday depending on what day
it is now if you steal a candy bar
that's wrong
but chances are you're not going to stay
until monday to see a judge and it's not
even in this bill that's correct but the
items that we're talking here
they're not going to let you out
you know you're going to be in handcuffs
and you're going to go to jail and
you're going to stay there until you see
a judge and then they're going to say
does this person get bail or does this
person not and then they're gonna state
the bail
you know thousand dollars cash bail or
200 000 um
you know cash bail
you know that's what's in my
you know eyes on this bill is you know
it's not needed it's it's just you know
we're trying to fix something that is
not
you know that
there's other other alternatives to
fixing the major problem here
and if we stick together we can do it
representative harry gathered then
representative newman
thank you mr chair um first of all i
just want to say ditto to
the representative from golftown
goffstown
um
i think he was from the department of
justice the one that gave you the
information about putting an exception
for rsa 597 colon 1c
and he also um told you because one of
his comment was there's no bail anyway
so basically he was trying to get you to
clean this up i guess a little bit
because um
these are things that are in place today
in new hampshire that you don't get
bailed for
um
it does say except that's provided in
rsa 597 colon 1 c
right so
it does it does address that concern by
the doj okay
and the other thing was that
for homicide you don't
there's no bail anyway
i mean so i guess
we have a bunch of rsas here
that already
apply
so
the essence of it if it's already law
it's already there why don't we have it
is that is that a question that's a
question yeah well
what you're doing is that you're
basically listing the these
violent offenses against a person or a
crime against a specific person
so you put homicide under there
if you have a separate section
which is 597
colon one sc
that's excluding that from this policy
but you put homicide in it which which
is much broader it doesn't homicide can
be
it's cap there's different there's
different types of homicides without
getting naming everyone
so you're kind of incorporating them all
under there
but there's no bail
for for some of them they they killed me
that's my understanding if i'm never
wrong with that someone can please
correct me
not every type
that's
but just to make my comment and be clear
um i am totally against the bill um
i think it's not necessary i think that
we have the laws in place today
um
i truly believe that
there is something that can come down
the line that might help with that
upfront upfront situation
um
of the blame that is usually put on a
certain group of people however
not just commissioners make mistakes but
you know
judges tend to they're home human as
well so sometimes um
it could be either way
representative newman
thank you mr chair
um i heard uh representative bird say
they shall be held in jail and i thought
i heard that no they may be released
and i'm confused because when i look at
line eight well let's start with line
seven
what which page number uh on page two
line seven and it's the amendment that
we passed
it says
um
if you're charged it starts at the top
it says recharge of those crimes and on
page on line 7 it says
shall not be brought before a baal
commissioner and shall
upon arrest
be detained pending arraignment before
the court
so
those words to me mean that
if you're arrested and non-court hours
you're not going to see a judge and you
will be detained so i just thought that
might
help out with my colleague john bird's
argument
your i think the confusion was in
the representative goffstown can correct
me was
being held up detained awaiting trial
where this policy would hold you and
you're detained awaiting your
arraignment which
is the first
after you're arrested
the bail
the bail hearing would be during the
arraignment it's literally the first
procedural step
taking the case
so there's a difference between
one
saying they can be held
pen wing trial
as opposed to just the arraignment so
we're talking the arraignment has to be
held
within 24 to 36 hours
obviously excluding the weekends and
holidays
because that's that's the longest you
would actually be held and now they have
if they find you a threat to public
safety
or a threat to yourself
that can that's something that the state
would have to ask for and meet the
burden of proof
and it's do you understand that's the
difference no i don't understand because
i look at this when i go back here and
to line 28 on page one it says when
considering whether to release or detain
the person the quoted faculty
commissioner
shall consider the following issues
safety or
the safety of the public or the
defendant
and then i assume
uh that i that this
item number one
refers to what they're considering
and so they get to consider all of that
but included in section one is that they
shall be held now i don't i don't want
to speak for my colleague but i my i was
thinking that he was saying that when
they get arrested they shall be detained
you shall be detained and you're telling
me well it's not so bad because they'll
be detained until the arraignment but
that's only 36 hours it's half of what
it used to be
i understand that that's how i
understand it i may be incorrect thank
you
you keep saying shall be detained and
it's a little bit i'm just gonna explain
all right
shall
not be brought before a bail
commissioner cut that shall
upon arrest be detained
pending arraignment before the court so
the detention period under that section
is just
to bring that person before the court
for an arraignment that is it that's the
only
part that's been established at that
point in time how long that person will
be held
anything where they're going to be held
in pre-trial detention after the
arraignment that is that is what's at
the second part of that section the
state would have to meet a separate
burden and that's assuming the state is
requesting that person to be held it
does not always happen
where does the second part begin i don't
see the second part
well
i said
be detained pending arraignment for the
court the next part arraignment shall
occur
no later than 24 hours after the arrest
that's on that is on line nine on pages
where is the person who has been
arrested for that 24 hours
he's in the jail he's in the cell
it almost seems to me
that pre-trial process
does everybody in the committee
understand that process i mean we ought
to have been on the committee for quite
some time
mr chairman committee i think everyone
here knows generally how i feel about
this bill
um
in particular the first section
yet we just went through a vote
that
really kind of tipped what the vote on
the house floor is going to be like
i don't know how that vote is going to
go
but it my
objective
would be to get something through the
house
right now
i'm not sure that this version is going
to get through the house
um
around this time last year when sb 92
came before the committee
i asked
the committee and i asked the chair to
hold on to it
the outcome wasn't what i would have
liked
but i might suggest
to the chair and to supporters of this
bill
to hold off on this for today
and maybe try again with an amendment
that is more likely to pass the house
that's unsolicited advice
but at this point i don't
i don't know what's going to happen
but it's a 50 50 at best
and i would hate to lose the good in
this bill
there is a lot of good
and all the work that's gone into it
on a tabling motion or who knows what so
i i guess i'm wondering if something
maybe could come forward in a week's
time
to find something that was more likely
to pass
and what would that look like
in your
well i've offered something that is
and i'm not saying the amendment is
great and perfect and wonderful because
i made it
it's a simpler build
many of the things that opponents have
latched onto
are not in it it deals with the
dangerousness the dangerous people the
dangerous crimes
and i think that alone is a win and i
don't want to see the
the good stuff in this bill
die
and i'm thinking that more work could be
done and furthermore out of deference to
my ranking member i would love to hear
more about her amendment
um
i know she's put a lot of work into it
and i think that the committee has
expressed interest in hearing it
so in respect to the magistrate
what i'm inclined to do
and i said this before is have a
separate ad hoc hearing
if it's a non-german amendment we have
other bills we could consider
adding that on to
i think what we want to do is it's
it's just but keep going down the road
of that adding that procedure onto this
procedure i mean you yourself just said
people have a difficult time
understanding the procedure
which is to be honest that's my biggest
concern with adding the magistrate idea
to this
is
making sure the procedure is understood
and even on my own and this is this this
is a court procedure's not easy to
follow
uh
legal experience or not so it's
something that i'm just saying i think
it would muddy the waters
but i
i want to do in the ad hoc hearing so we
can kind of go through it as a committee
but are we going to be able to do that
on this bill i mean again
the policies here i think
and correct me if i'm wrong you were
referencing perhaps just having a
section of the bill an amendment that
would only have
essentially be lines 1 through 20 on
page 2. it may have some of the
beginning procedural sections on the
first page as well but if we just had
that and didn't deal with the other
sections
in our debates i mean
and i mean disrespect any members of the
committee we're still debating the
interpretation of that
and so when i say make it simpler
i'm struggling to understand some of
these
other provisions
what the amendment we previously passed
would have addressed if someone
continues to miss court hearings would
there be a consequence for that
we took that out
we left that we're leaving that as
existing law
and i'm referencing the amendment that
was passed
uh
in respect to 295 in respect to senate
bill 92.
so i'm not sure what what other con
whatever confusion there is
mr chairman i don't by any means think
that it's confusion uh i think that
people don't support the policy outlined
i think that well we just saw that there
was a narrow vote that supported the
policy of the amendment
this has been a two-year effort
across two chambers
and i would hate to see that work
come to nothing
and i i just think that the vote we just
had portends a rocky path ahead and i'm
i'm wondering if more could be done to
get to a point where we're more likely
to pass it
i think once we have a finished product
we'll get a better idea of that
the problem is is that
even this amendment is a pretty
drastic change
i um jurassic is the right word but
there's some significant changes to 92.
so
representative has any members who
haven't spoken already that wish to
speak
any questions about any other sections
of the bill
any
misunderstandings
any comments
this time
representative bourne
uh thank you mr chair
um
i like most of the people except for you
have really little experience with the
criminal justice system
uh terry as well
um
and i think a lot of these i did i'm
sorry about representative o'hearn all
hearn also but
that is major a minority of of the
committee
and i'm wondering if we need a really
sort of a
mock
procedure of where we arrest people
detain them have bell hearings and
up to
a court appearances as just a way to
un make us understand
the process because right now all we
know is what we hear
uh
abstractly or we see on tv
because most of us
are do not appear in criminal court we
don't know what goes there all we hear
is rumors but that is just a suggestion
for something to do in the future i mean
maybe we could even get
a member of the
professor to lead us through such a
thing
anyway that is just
that's off that's just sort of a idea i
i don't think it's a bad idea to have
some type of flow chart perhaps
put together by
i'm sure someone may help me do that
but i think that part part of the issue
and again that goes back to my concern
about
respect to representative
uh eric gathwaite's amendment is
i'm not allowed to mention it but it's
it's again it's it's the complexities of
it so that's my again
point taken representative schultz
well on that note
thank you mr chair um
you know
i am still not really a member of this
committee but i really appreciate
participating so i do want to add that
as a caveat
but i keep trying to find a list of new
hampshire bail commissioners on multiple
websites run
by that
it's you can't find it my point is just
that
for so many reasons the existing law
for whatever purpose
should be enough
and
i believe i believe that is a known fact
by more people than would admit
i'll just
and i'm inclined to follow um
my ranking member with her vote
i believe at the last public hearing
there was they don't make the names
public
i i just so you don't
don't keep looking for it the first
they're kept private for confidential
for a reason
and then um
i think there was less
i it was mentioned during testimony last
hearing we had on friday i don't
remember the exact number i want to say
it was around set between 70 and 80.
but there's a lot of vacancies and
they're having trouble filling
those so
but judges are a part of their
appointments public so i mean it's
a public appointment you know they're
appointed than the executive council so
they those the names of the judges are
public yes but bill commissioner
representative welch
mr chairman
this is really
directed at representative boarding
he should go down to the manchester
court i think it's on a monday morning
when they hold the arraignments see what
the process is i've been there i took
the committee there several years back
and it's really
it's horrifying
to tell you the truth
and i talked to a woman down there who
was
a victim of domestic assault and i
overheard
the conversation
that the guy stuck a gun right in her
face
well
i guess he got locked up
good good enough for him but you ought
to go down and see how it works
rather than listen to somebody tell you
how it works
that's all
any members wish to speak that haven't
spoken already
parliamentary inquiry mr chairman
you're so recognized thank you could you
explain how
practically this committee could hear
uh an amendment on a magistrate system
and whether in your opinion such a bill
could be acted upon this term
so
two things
we could have an ad hoc hearing at that
point we can discuss any issue that's
within the purviews committee we don't
need a bill
so we can do
discuss that now if
it's a non-germain amendment
we would have to notice that so we could
technically do that with any bell
it doesn't have to be one involving
veil at all we could
do that we just would need in one it
would have to be ruled non-drained by
the speaker
and then we have to notice the hearing
separate
we can do that on any bill
at any you know i don't say any time but
that that's the process we can do if we
have other bills in the committee
there'll also be some second committee
bills we can do
if i may follow up
is it
your belief then that we would have an
avenue to pursue that if the committee
were so inclined there are enough there
are bills and there are bills that could
be tacked on too
it can be literally any bill it can be
tacked onto as a non-german amendment a
non-drain amendment so yes we have other
bills
that my understand would be coming to
this committee
i'm not clear if there's any second
committee bills i haven't looked at
every single senate bill but there are
other
policies so i mean other bills that we
can do a non-german amendment on and i'm
willing to at least
consider doing that and
okay lastly sorry everyone to belabor
this so what does that mean are we
saving a bill from today are we gonna
to exec or
to make sure that we have something
along those lines
what
let's go well that's a good point we
all the early deadline bills we we
finished the exec on all those
on
friday
so
could we meet again yes i think we could
exec everything
maybe as long as the bill is in the
committee even if we execute
we could still hold on to the bill
and then move for reconsideration at
later time
i'm i guess my my concern is is that
the procedure is what we're going to be
more discussing i think it's very clear
we all like a system involving
magistrates at some point i just think
we got to figure out the procedure that
those magistrates will follow
and that's that's a that's where the
real debate's going to happen
so i i'll be honest
you know a
i know a lot of people like these
study committee or a commission would
probably be the way to go
discussing the different
policies but we can do that in an ad hoc
hearing which would accomplish that goal
and i'm sure our friends from the court
will show up at that
ad hoc hearing and at that point we
would we would have a better idea on how
to do this and what direction to go
that's just that's my opinion because
that's that is a major change
in the law it's not as to me it's not as
simple as just a light switch from one
to the other
and i i don't know how long the hiring
process would take there's a lot to go a
lot of goes into that
representative manjuputi
thank you mr chairs sorry to belabor but
if you are a if you're saying if i
understand you correctly
the amendment that uh representative
harriet gathright has brought in that
can be non-domain can be attached to any
bill if it is any bill why not attach to
the bill that we have on hand that is
related that's all my question so
you're asking my in my opinion
well number one we would have to merge
that into
up
into the current amendment number one
number two
is the difficult debate that we're
having on policy and procedure that said
magistrates will have to follow which as
you can tell we don't all agree on
so
i think we need to have that discussion
separate that's my opinion when i say
can be a non-german amendment can be
brought up on any amendment that's
by non-germanic means it's not relevant
to the original bill so
it can be done
so i just my concern is again the
procedure
it's let's
separate those two policy decisions and
debate it that way that's just that's my
opinion
do any any members wish to speak that
have not spoken already
he's already spoke represented welch
did he speak did you speak already
my my suggestion is that if we were to
entertain a non-german amendment
and merge it with a current bill you
could have
two effective dates
section one effective
whenever this one is
and the section two which would probably
be the magistrate uh bill would be
effective a year later
i i understand that can be done but the
policy that's inside the amendments the
amendment right now
1509 still needs to
make it out in order to
be considered so again putting them
together
you may lose the magistrate because of
the policy decision or some people may
not not want
may not want the match we have we
haven't heard that we haven't really
floated that beyond
this room today and i know i've talked
to some other reps about it and
it's kind of we're kind of gearing up
for that but
i think if we rush that out right now
yeah i i point well taken
at this time well now
the plenty of people spoke like four
times
i've spoke once
i'm recognized you to speak i just all
right
you're up thank you
um to my friend in front of me
yes
any dream that this is going to happen
is a dream
and you know that possibly we could
attach something on because let me
explain
we have house next thursday
we also have have house on thursday the
fifth with keep wednesday open
because that's when everything has to be
done so there's zero chance that we're
gonna do anything in the next two weeks
to get this out because after the fifth
if i don't have the calendar in front of
me but if i remember reading it right
that's the end we're done and then we
have house on the 12th and the 26th and
we're done for the year
until next election so
you know so if you're voting yes on this
just
to hope have a hope i'm going to dash
your hope sorry
but you're a friend and i i think you
should deserve the truth thank you
representative byrd we're always
available to meet on fridays as well
just in case you uh
kept up with the schedule when the
committee regularly meets which are
wednesdays and fridays that is correct
so that is something that we can
make arrangements for if we still wish
and we have other bills and then there's
also some potential for second committee
bills that can be assigned to the
committee
we would have those as well
yes and the chair can waive those off
which he has in the past
i could
at this time
we now move we'll now move the question
if you in support of the motion of ought
to pass as amended
we say yay you are opposed if you are
opposed
please say hey the clerk will not call
the roll
vice chairman roy
yes
representative welch
representative burrick
no
representative rhodes yes
representative greene
clerk votes yes representative testament
representative genegan yes
representative pratt
yes
representative marston
representative harriet gathright
representative manager poody
no
representative hearn
representative bourdain no
representative schultz no
representative ray newman
no
representative van
no representative conley no
representative bradley no
representative espitia no
chairman abbas
chair votes yes
nine yays 11 nays
ocean fails
so representative conley
which what's your what's your
desire to do here now
would you like to be recognized to make
a motion
i'm not sure what that motion would be
right now
truly
well the ought to pass as amended didn't
work
so
there's a the options interim study
which i wouldn't recognize someone for
that
because
this committee studied it long enough
would you like to make a motion of you
can do reconsideration or an experience
to legislate mr chairman i'd move to
reconsider amendment
well
it's the the octopass's amendment you
the ought to pass as amended is
what would need to be reconsidered
could the amendment not be reconsidered
now with the floor open we would
actually that's parliamentary inquiry
so mr chairman i said exactly
my feelings on the bill when i spoke a
few minutes ago
let's get something that can pass
and i don't think this can pass i don't
think it will pass
so
my suggestion
would be to think on it for a little bit
even if it's a couple days
and try to get there
and but i i would not be supporting an
ito at this time
so let me ask you this we have several
other amendments here if you want to
reconsider what we've adopted
which ones are we working with here
mr chairman i'd move amendment 15308
well that's the amendment that you would
we would have to reconsider but which
one is that
you want to just make so you just want
to consider the
violent crimes section we'll call it mr
chairman i think that that uh would have
an easier time passing we have 1476 with
deals with repeat offenders while on
bail
we heard on the house floor the prime
opponent of hb 1476 specifically saying
that these provisions in sb 294 or a
reason to vote for the bill
and i don't want the baby thrown out
with the bathwater
well what's
that's
again i don't actually i don't actually
have a copy of your amendment
but let me let me ask you one one
question if we did that
what is what is the objection you
believe that's going to happen with the
other sections of
i mean i understand this is simplex only
addresses one section
of the bill
so
there's something that we all understand
about somebody accused of a violent
crime
they are not we know we just heard
testimony from the
attorney general's office
that more often than not people under
this whole basket of crimes in our state
including those here other than homicide
including child
pornography including second-degree
assault
are let out more often than not
this addresses that basic point
without the other points that could
uh
that opponents have raised the litany of
issues opponents have raised time and
again are gone so we focus on the
violent crimes we go ahead with 1476
and we have a a pretty significant
change to our bail statute that
addresses probably 90 percent of what
everybody who supports the reform
wants to get
and i believe it would pass
i don't remember anybody
forgive me if i misspoke
so what when you list these offenses
under
what is 1503 that amendment i'm just
asking you what's the difference between
that and the policy we have
under 1509
i think the second section of 1509
is the primary i'm not speaking for
anyone i know that there are people in
this room who won't support this
on principle
but this is a far this is a
simple
and it doesn't have the secondary
effects of
all that is contained in 294 beyond this
point this is something if you ask any
person on the street
i think nine out of 10 would agree that
these people should go before a judge
keep it simple keep it to that and i
think
it's a it's a successful bill
parliamentary inquiry mr
you're so recognized
um i just have a curiosity about the
process we're talking about an amendment
and whatever's going to happen if if in
fact that motion is made when we have a
discussion about that
yes thank you i i i guess where i
disagree with the representative from
dover is that when i asked any members
of the committee
what are their objections to the other
sections of the bill beyond
which was lines one through twenty on
page two i did not hear any any
objections to that
i did not hear complaints about that
from any member
so
i understand we're worried about i i'm
not clear that the
people who support the policy
i'm not sure we're changing many votes
with that that's not that doesn't seem
to be where the debate is
the debate is the bail commissioner and
i'll be honest some of the
some of the language in there is really
clarifying the existing language
i mean the debate has been
lines 1 through 20
on page 2 of
hb1509
that's where we've been dealing with
this the most today that's where we
focused on but a lot of the past
discussion on this that has sort of
baked into this is the back half of the
bill
and
this has been the focus today
but um
the the opponents that i've heard from
are less concerned far less concerned
about this stuff and far more concerned
about the second half of the bill
you're correct they they took exception
with the language rebuttable presumption
which is under existing law
the language that is in the bill
so the rebuttable presumption language
was not something i came up with
uh as a point of being creative they're
saying that that's unconstitutional well
i don't agree with that but to the
extent even if they're correct that
rebuttable presumption language is in
the law already
so
it's not shifting the burden now the two
other sections that dealt with that one
of them was the section on
whether a person continues to miss court
hearings
at by the third time or the second time
the same case would that person
be held and to overcome the rebuttable
presumption well that language i
in this amendment is this existing law
the only other i this is just objections
i've heard from
non-elected
members and i've heard this from even
some elected members
uh
the issue is if you get arrested three
times so you're out on bail you get
arrested again
and now we're talking a class a
misdemeanor drunk driving or a felony
yeah you get a you get let out you're
now on bill you've been arrested twice
and out on bill on both those you get
arrested now a third time
for class a misdemeanor drunk driving or
a felony at that point
in that bill in that section
again the existing law says rebuttable
presumption
but this clarifies that language because
my understanding that that's been
interpreted differently
so we have that so that's the other
objection to it and i understand people
oppose that
but i'm just explaining
the rash the rationale that's being
presented has to do with the lang terms
rebuttable presumption which the
existing law has that so i
i guess defeat the bill congratulations
but that problem will exist whether this
password order
yes
we recognize for your point of order
there was too much is there a motion on
the floor that has been seconded
no we're just having a discussion
we're debating i was trying to encourage
my
my friend from dover to make a motion of
unexpecting to legislate or
reconsideration
and and
may i be recognized for making a motion
i
i'm going to leave it to representative
calmly to make a motion
if he's free to pass if he doesn't want
to make one
do i have a choice in motion i would
make
yeah i can't make you do anything it's
free mr chairman i would move amendment
1503 and then i would ask given that
we've had a lengthy back and forth to
move the question fairly quickly and if
that fails
uh i still would not support itl i would
support
a pause to try and fix a bill that will
pass but uh we'll let's cross that
bridge when we get there
can okay well
let me just i see a show of hands on
1503 how how many members of this
committee would support that policy
passing
we i don't i didn't i didn't see the
majority of hands raised
some want to do a recount if you would
support and ought to pass as amended and
it's now 1503 you get what i'm saying it
that would need to pass the committee
too
and i will put my hand up because i
don't think having
1503 is better than having nothing but
let me ask
who would support that
and just
there's a four
wait
perhaps a floor amendment would be the
way to go if that's the case because but
we would need a positive motion i'm just
explaining we don't
i don't i don't think i don't i don't
think the point that's raised by my
friend from dover is a bad point but we
need to we would need to before we do
all these reconsider all this stuff we
need to actually pass it in the
committee i just did to save us time
shot raise your hand no we didn't we
don't have the votes to do that either
so
questions
is representative connolly the only
person who can make a motion on
at this point or can anyone else make a
motion
he's not obligated to make a motion i'm
just asking if he wants to
okay no i miss
well we would have to recon we would
have to reconsider the
we would have to get rid of the actual
amendment my understanding right
we would have to because we already
passed the amendment
so we would have to reconsider that
but what i so what i'm getting at is we
can reconsider the adoption of 1509
i'm trying to get a feel whether 1503
would actually pass and and the answer
from what i understand is it's short on
vote so that going down that road i
don't think is going to get us anywhere
so i guess now what's what's our other
option here can i make a motion
i i guess let's let's consider another
motion but i'm making clear now that i
will not be supporting itl
if you reconsider the author passes
amended would you
be inclined to vote a different way
you and i worked discussed this in
detail we worked together
we have discussed this at length um
i don't know if if we can't even agree
on section one
uh as a committee
i think that suggests where this bill is
headed
we don't have a deadline that says we
have to do this today
i
and i guess i'm saying i'm not ready to
concede defeat on this
so is there
a could we sit could we pause this for a
week could we pause this till friday
we would have to notice it so it's not
notice for
deadlines
we would have to reconsider it so
mr chairman i would move to reconsider
amendment 1509
so we're reconsidering 1509. now you are
you
i i think i misspoke mr chairman
representative
okay
um my understanding is that
ought to pass as amended failed
so how can you go back
and pull that amendment
we would have to reconsider that go then
we would have to then reconsider the we
have to use go with a different
amendment we would have to reconsider
that as well adopting that
so my question to everyone is is if we
did all that would that other amendment
actually pass in the committee and the
feeling i get is no it will not based on
the hands raised
so i'm kind of i'm kind of lost where
where go other than extreme to legislate
this point or interim study
so can we get to a point
we can just pass a clean bill no
amendments i mean what are the sense of
the committee
just past 294
as is
and deal with
with floor amendments
that that's that's an option too
could we send it
needs an amendment anyhow it's got a
wrong reference of the irsa in there
if you recall
what's the wrong reference
well the under you're talking about the
original bill the original bill
yes
on line 25 page one
references i was a
6 30 call on one it should be 6 30.
on line 26.
no that was identified by that one
yes so 9 26
oh uh line 25 i'm sorry
no 6 30 call on one should be six i'm
going to give my friend from dover hint
if we don't reconsider the octopus
amendment i'm going to be inclined to
repres recognize my friend from keene to
make a motion which i
uh most next meeting to legislate
mr chairman we had a
motion and we had a second
we had a straw vote
i don't want it to go to interim study
or
i agree no interns i don't so what i'm
going to say is it's ought to pass this
man it failed
i think i'm i'm
if people want to vote
and they don't want to hold criminals
who commit violent crimes against people
and child pornography and point of order
but you're making motive here
i'll gather myself i apologize
am i allowed to gather myself you know
you you know
it's already i already i apologize
already but i'm just saying i'm inclined
to let
it when that's that's what it is
we don't have to we're not going to pass
it we'll do go that wrong
mr chairman there was a motion made in a
second we have not discussed the
amendment specifically what the
amendment would do
i would like a vote on the amendment
you're you're a man yes okay so we in
procedure my understanding is we have to
now
re still reconsider the author pass as
amended
right
no
don't we have to get rid of the first
amendment
it was the amendment was adopted we have
to now
mr chairman i i text the clerk he says
we have to reconsider
that's what i'm trying to say i'm trying
to get someone to make a motion to
reconsider the ought to pass as amended
yes i
people want to reconsider another
if they won't do that then it's an itl
mr chairman i would move i would
reconsider move reconsideration on ought
to pass on sb 294 and move an amendment
when appropriate so octopass is amended
that's that's that's what it is is there
a second
that's been segment representative rory
and i would move amendment 1503 and if i
may speak to it no we don't do it at
this time you can't do it
so we have to reconsider the passage
amended
this is new hampshire
all right i'm gonna explain we
the octopass is amended right we need to
reconsider
so
we have to reconsider the adoption
of
amendment 1509
that needs to not be what it what we do
okay
so which it's
it's the weather to adopt amendment 1509
all right that's my understanding what
we have to do next
all right so we're going to reconsider
that
and
you need to
i'm confused now
yes once it's reconsidered then it's
whether to adopt it
at that point i would just pray that
representative roy withdraws his motion
toward
to
introduce that amendment and then i'll
recognize the representative from dover
so that it it's motion the motions to
reconsider
adopting
amendment 1509
and that was is that second that's the
most you have to make uh to pass as
amendment is the motion
that motion failed oh
the
just reconsider the amendment right
we're reconsidering the amendment so
moved you can't read
if someone thinks we're not following
the rules that it's a point of order but
in order to we cannot consider
my friend from dover's amendment
we cannot do it
unless we reconsider the adoption of
1509 that amendment i don't know how
many more times i can say that without
explaining it any other way it needs to
be
we got to reconsider that
all right that is what we have to do
because we only can adopt one amendment
and i've said that i want to say
10 times
so i'm trying to get us to that point
but no one wants to do that either
so
bear with me here
you have a i'm not going to recognize
anyone for any questions right now i'm
representing represent colony you wish
to do a reconsideration of 1509. so
moved is there a second there you go the
second by representative welch
representative burt you have your hand
raised let's just discuss the question
yes i think you need to talk to the
clerk because my understanding is we
have to reconsider ought to pass as
amended it has nothing to do with who
the amendment is or what the amendment
is or anything we have to
get rid of the ought to pass as amended
and then move forward so once we do that
then he can bring the
amendments in are you suggesting
the octopass is amended failed
but we have to reconsider it and then
it's a blank then then there's nothing
then it's all done you know it's like we
never voted
then we say okay now what do we want to
do then we move forward within the you
know and not to pass amendment with this
you know with uh no representative i'm
gonna go into i'm gonna i'm gonna go
into recess i'm not sure what clerk what
question you you've presented to the
clerk i can write i tell you i got it
right here
i roll in criminal justice okay do you
want me to tell you
listen what we're going to do
if someone does not believe i'm
following the rules properly they can
raise a point of war that's what they're
for all right point of order
please stay your
please state your point of order
all right the point of order is i'm
reading from the clerk that the only
option here is reconsider
of the ought to pass as amended then it
gives us a clean slate the bill has done
nothing i'm going to go into the
criminal justice committee will be in
recess for
i think what bernie's saying is that
eliminates the amendment correct it
eliminates everything would it okay that
would eliminate the amendment as well
correct that is the proper motion
so we want to reconsider the ought to
pass as amended all right but i'm going
to go into recess for five minutes i
want to speak to the clerk make sure
we're doing it properly thank you
okay
to do that
do you have something you want to put in
1476 that's not there
okay i don't think they will work out
there's nothing that's right
sorry
right there rosberry
yes
no
now
okay
just what your meetings
he wants to take
that's interesting
well that's not necessarily
a democrat
oh yeah yeah
i am supporting them but also
right now
right right
but just between you and me
he don't have enough experience
and if i was in salem i wouldn't vote
for him
this is his second term
and they shoveled him
experience
he's
sitting in one of those
chairs
i've also been in this committee when we
had
and so i was here on
criminal justice
now
prior to this term
i'm thinking it's two terms five
this one ends here it was my second term
in the house my first term i was in
elected law second term i would have
become
then i didn't
so
and i've come to my final conclusion
what i'm gonna do come on selection
i'm going to spend my two weeks
put my name in
and see what happens
i might put up a few signs at some point
i gotta you know because i go
and i might not if i get elected
terrific if i don't get elected
no i don't know him and i ain't
expecting we talk about the same
and i don't mean any
no i'm just kind of one of my things
that i finally have come to the
conclusion
one of the things about lawyers they
want to talk to me
and they only allow 15 minutes for it
here
he just introduced the bill the next
person after him was a lawyer who spoke
for 25 minutes
you see and it's like they have to keep
things moving along the center because
they've got so few of them i don't know
how to do it
well one of the things that i noticed
that i
wouldn't
i would do it if i was a chair at any
point i don't ever expect to be but my
point is i would schedule a bill at
10 at 10 15 at 10 30 you know and so
every 15 minutes
no you're not gonna they're not going to
knock off but the point is
when you get ready to call a bill you're
either in the room that you want to open
up and testify
and that's what the senate does that's
how they do it they do it every 30
minutes
you know that has that that has some
validity
because what we end up doing in the
house side
okay well we'll schedule it at this time
and then we'll wait an hour an hour and
a half but what have you done in 15
minutes
now we're all sitting around pulling our
thumbs up that happens
usually it's the other way but that does
happen too exactly and on the flip side
of that is these people that want to
come in and testify they
if you told them they weren't going to
open this bill until
11 they're not going to show up
they're out having
tea and trumpets yeah
so i'm just saying yeah
there's a lot to be said for both
the way the house where new hampshire
runs bills and legislates
i look at it and say you know what
there's something to be said about the
way they do it in washington
i'm not saying i'm picking one over the
other but i love the idea that in
washington if a chairman of a committee
don't like your bill it ain't seeing the
light of day
whereas in new hampshire you put in a
bill not only does it see the light of
day it's going to get a hearing in the
full house right up and down it doesn't
matter
and i mean i get a kick i mean
a bill comes in
a bill goes to commencement the bill
gets hashed out he's driving over
finally goes to the clerk's office
i don't care how it is
about to pass
it doesn't matter
but it also can go on a consent calendar
stands up and says i wanna i wanna table
the bill
all right we will now reopen the
executive session
on senate bill 294 i believe the open
question was
there was a motion to
reconsider the ought to pass as amended
at this time we will now move the
question
if you support the motion to reconsider
the octopass is amended please say yay
if you're
opposed
please say nay the clerk will not call
the roll
vice shaman roy
vice chairman rivals no
representative welch
no
representative burt
representative rhodes
no
representative greene
clerk votes no
representative testament no
representative genegion
yes
representative pratt
no
representative marston
representative harriet gathright
reconsideration
motion to reconsider
the motion of octopass is amended no
representative manjuputi
no
representative o'hearn
representative boardney no
representative schultz no
representative newman
no representative anne
no
representative casey
actually they represent conley yes
[Laughter]
representative bradley
no
representative espitia no chairman abbas
did
i change yes you may yeah i misspoke no
chair votes no
19-2 reconsideration fails
oh i'm sorry that's correct john
by a vote of 19 to 1 the reconsideration
fails
representative calling you wish to make
another motion
of it you wish to make one of the enix
being to legislate
mr chairman i'm not going to make that
motion because i don't support that uh
action
representative bourdain you recognize to
make a motion
make a motion to uh itl and i'll second
it's been seconded by representative
burt
representative borden do you wish to
speak to your motion
uh yes i do
uh
this bill is not necessary uh it makes
the court system uh
worse off than it is today and already
the court system was backlogged who
knows how long
i did talk to
court officials during the lunch break
and
they don't know when if ever they will
ever catch up
so
adding more case load to the
court system is not going to help
and just
so
other upper rep other reps in the
committee know
already
for domestic
violence situations
current law
does support being able to retain people
that's all thanks
representative burt you were recognized
thank you mr chairman i support the itl
again as i said in the past
this bill is not needed
if you read
well if you read
the underlying bill
the people that they
want to
hold they can hold now according to the
new hampshire ag
thank you and i hope you support the itl
by voting yes
representative connolly you're
recognized mr chairman thank you
so
i don't even know what we're i guess
we're voting on itl of the amended bill
which does a lot of things
let me just correct that
when it's a motion of index being to
legislate there's no amendment
so it's the underlying we're back to the
the indie experience legislates
discussing the underlying bill
not the any amendment at this point and
just for a point of clarification
and to my friend from nashua the ranking
member the
amendment that you had prepared i
received word that that was
ruled a non-germain amendment
so
i don't i don't want this to
so i don't know what's happening after
this i don't know what's going on i
don't want the policy to die
i'll be voting against itl
and
rather than subject hopefully not
subject this committee to another round
of
motion upon motion
but i aired in my original vote i made a
mistake
i don't like that i made that mistake
and i am hoping that there's an
opportunity to undo that mistake by
bringing the the bill back in its
amended form if that's the only form
we're going to get
we were told by law enforcement
something needs to be done
we were told
by our district by our county attorneys
something needs to be done
we were told by the attorney general's
office they support the bill these are
the people who deal with people who
break laws in our state
it's not
respectfully the aclu
respectfully the people on twitter
those are the people who deal with
people who commit crimes
they want this to pass
i trust their judgment and i am
uh kicking myself for the mistake i made
and i'm sorry that everyone had to
listen to that
but that's the way i feel
representative schultz you're recognized
thank you mr chair
um
i genuinely genuinely believe we
genuinely all care about
making sure people who are
have perpetrated violence
indeed should be punished i think we all
agree with that
um
what we really
don't always understand as lawmakers and
i guess i should just say i speak only
for myself
just in life in general
what i think what is going to work or be
helpful as an action
is not always true
the things we think that might make us
happy aren't always true the things that
we think are going to do a lot of things
especially as legislators don't aren't
always the most effective way
and i do genuinely believe all of us
care about safety
and we disagree
plain and simple we disagree
i'm of the camp that believes strongly
that bail reform was
the right thing to do it remains the
right thing to do and we just need to
enforce the laws on the books
um
and we led the way in many ways in the
nation and
um
so we need to work on the things we need
agree on and go from there that's my
suggestion thank you
representative tessman
um
i too would like to see
you know
bail reform work
what i hear from uh dr shear and others
is it it's good i'm not sure i really
agree with him but what i also hear is
that we've got a bunch of numb skulls
as bill comments
excuse me representative testament
let's not make making any generalized
statements like that especially using
that terminology
that's not and that's not that's not
fair so i just ask
see with caution we have
we have a group of
people commissioners
who are obviously not well trained
please
it's not their fault
anyway we need to fix the bail
commissioners
and you know that's where the
the issue is right now there may be a
magistrate thing coming later
so what uh but the
the the the whole really seems to be
with the bail commissioners
representative o'hara
just a question for the chair because
i'm
after these long hours here i'm getting
a little confused
so
this right now we're inexp to legislate
on
the amended
because because of the reconsideration
the underlying bill
because when in order to discuss an
amendment there needs to be a positive
motion
we are we are past that point now
there was an attempt to reconsider
to perhaps get to a point where a
different
amendment could be offered
but we did not get to that point
so now we're talking about the
underlying bill
representative newman and the underlying
bill means the way it came from the
senate
is that correct
yes thank you
do any members wish to speak that
haven't spoken already
i i will point out i do appreciate the
effort we put into this
however this was not a repeal
of
the bail reform that passed
this was a narrow focus on what i would
say
with some of the more egregious
situations
and
that's what this was intended to do
someone who gets arrested
five times for drunk driving in a
two-month time period
is still able to get
be released
i think if someone were to be arrested
for that many times for that offense in
a short time period
is something else going on
but the issue is
it's bail they're being
being allowed to be let out on bail that
puts the public safety at risk puts all
of us everyone at risk and even
themselves at risk
this was a this was an opportunity to
address that where if that person was
arrested for three times
for drunk driving at that point
it would be a rebuttable presumption
that that person would not abide by the
conditions of their release i i will say
in respect to bail generally
if you have conditions of your release
and you don't follow them and there's
zero consequence
for violating the conditions of your
release i'm not even sure why there is a
system of bail in the first place
there's absolutely no accountability no
consequence if those conditions are not
followed
i'm not saying that because someone
violates the conditions of their release
that they should automatically be held
waiting trial just out for in a
violation but if there's repeated
violations
of those conditions
what is this what is the solution to get
have someone have some accountability
and actually make an effort to comply
with those
and we had a list of offenses all these
offenses were violent offenses
against an individual we didn't have
crimes against property per se
they you know arson's not on the list
which i mean let's just go i'm going to
go right down the list you have assault
felonious sexual
assault
domestic violence
second degree assault homicide first
degree assault
kidnapping
stalking trafficking of of a person
human trafficking these are these are
the offenses that was the intention
to address these egregious situations
that's what we were dealing with
i we also had child pornography
robbery
and anyone who contains any
child pornography images
and the rationale for that is that if
you are containing those images you're
supporting the industry of child
pornography that's consistent with how
the supreme court united states is ruled
that's what this was we were trying to
address
and
our recommendation from this committee
i'm not going to support any expedition
to legislate
but that's but that's where we're at
right now
representative harry catherine
thank you mr chair again um i think we
address in hp 1476
and hp 1476 i think we addressed the
issue of um
releasing a defendant pending trial
and while out on bail
um
retaining those folks
so
um
but what i want to say about all the
different rsas that are listed there
today
they can be held
so to say that we don't have the laws
today
and my opinion is not true
the laws are there
people choose to either do them or or
not do them
so i don't think that's a setback for
this committee because i think everybody
in this committee cares about public
safety
but all we're saying is that today these
things are there
we've done our job by having the laws
so for me yes i will vote itl on that
bill
because it's not necessary it's already
part of the law today
right now this the the clarification
representative it has to do with the
police have the discretion to
pick and choose which people they want
held and don't want to offer a bail
commission to which ones they don't and
the idea is not leave that in the
discretion of the police
and that often is the decision that's
made from
outside the department that's my
understanding but in respect to 1476
that's
that was not going to be that has to do
with someone who's arrested while out on
bail
that's not whether to revoke that
person's bill that's when i'm
referencing a repeat offender
that section does something different
all right i was talk that's under
paragraph two
that's two
um
i'll make sure i get the right section
for you
anyway paragraph eight was 1476 and that
had to do with simply holding the person
to be brought before a judge for
violating the conditions of the release
by getting arrested again not right not
whether to revoke the bail so when to
say we addressed that problem for repeat
offenders we
it was not a it was not addressed
i
did some
it's an avoidant
representative roy
thank you um
like you i i can't support an itl on
this um
i've heard someone say you know that we
have the existing laws in place and
let's let the system work we've already
got these laws
the problem is is that
they're not being held in many cases
and you know there's finger pointing as
to who's to blame for that um
but basically at the end of the day
we're asking
bail commissioners who came before us
most recently
and told us that you know 40 to 60 of
the time they're not being paid so we're
putting the the safety of of some
granite staters in the hand of basically
volunteers
and asking them to make these decisions
and and it appears that you know in some
cases it's not being made
correctly we through this bill would
have specified
where people have to be held for a judge
to review
and
by kicking that down the road it just
leaves the status quo and um we've heard
from the chiefs of police from citizens
it's it's not working the way it is it
needs to be tweaked
and um i just can't support i can't
support
an itl in knowing that there are
domestic violence victims and some of
these people who are subject to people
just being released
on pr
in the decision being made like i said
by someone who's basically a volunteer
or at the very least not very happy
about their job because we're not paying
them
um so i won't be supporting the idea
represent bournemouth
uh thank you uh
uh mr roy uh
referenced that we had people testify
that uh it wasn't working
i have a list of the people that
testified on this bill
and
of the seven groups of people that
testified only one of them were was for
the bill and that was some police
officers that is it
all the others were against the bill
i'm sorry
uh bossie was here because he but he
didn't testify he just basically
introduced the bill
so
uh
hearing lots of evidence about our
testimony that uh
the bill the bill reform is not working
is not quite
correct
in my opinion
representative espitia thank you mr
chair and
in response to just some of the comments
i know that you know
if in fact that we're thinking that some
of the folks who are making these
decisions are
quote volunteers then i think we need to
look at more of what's going on you know
behind the scenes and looking at ways
that we can find a better platform to
try to get this you know uh try to get a
lot of these folks
um you know through pre-trial and
through enterprise and processed because
obviously it's not working right now um
so
i don't unfortunately this bill doesn't
address that and um you know i'll be
voting yes to the itl
representative parliamentary inquiry yes
i'm just curious to know
how many people signed in and support or
opposition
online and in person that
if you have that available
i don't have that information in front
of me
that's a person
and this time the we'll now move the
question if you're in support of the
motion banks being to legislate please
say yes
if you are opposed
uh please say no the clerk will not call
the roll vice chairman roy
no representative welch
no
representative burke
yes
representative rhodes
no
representative greene
clark votes no
representative testament no
representative genegan
no
representative pratt
representative marston
no
representative harriet gathright
yeah
representative manjuputi
yes representative o'hearn
no
representative boardney
yes representative schultz yes
representative newman
yes
representative vann yes
representative conley no
representative bradley
yes
representative espitia yes
chairman abbas
share votes no
11 nays
nine yays
the bill's itl
just the motion the motion fails
mr chairman
representative pratt
motion not to pass without amendment
second
all right
just bear with me
just bear with me for a moment
and i'm just gonna i miss my
understanding is
if we wanted to move ought to pass
whether as originally written
my understanding is that we would still
need to reconsider
we would have to reconsider the ought to
pass as amended
i don't think i'm not clear does the
no
it's awesome
representative pratt you recognized to
make a motion about to pass
okay ought to pass without amendment
well just ought to pass okay just about
to pass has that been seconded
i'll second
that has been seconded by representative
marston
parliamentary inquiry of the chair
you're so recognized
having supported the amendment
there is no amendment before the
campaign um forgive me having uh
supported a prior amendment
i believe that was 1509 that did pass
the committee
are we barred from reconsidering that
are we barred from voting on that again
not reconsidering it
but putting that back on the bill
let me rephrase
you're asking of 15 the amendment which
was 2022-150
can be offered again
i'm not clear that it can but
2022-1486h can
we have a motion in a second
that right now listen right now the
motion is ought to pass and there's a
second
mr chair
representative pratt you wish to speak
to your motion about to pass
having debated this extensively on
multiple occasions
i feel this bill has a lot to offer
and
at the end of each paragraph on pages
two and three and four
and it clarifies the paragraph and adds
to it positive
things
and then also in many places where it
says may it makes it shea shell
i believe all those are important
additions
i think if we go back to the pure bill
and voted through i think we'll be doing
the state of new hampshire great service
representative harry catherine
thank you mr chair
um if i look at this the art to pass
um reconsideration failed itself failed
so with the amendment so how can you
bring back an amendment when it already
it's the underlying bill if there was
another amendment offered
but that's i will say respectfully
representative harry gathway the
amendment that you had prepared is
has already been ruled non-germane
so that can one that can be taken up at
any point in time on any bill
may i just float an idea without
creating any more confusion that we
already have
thanks thank you thanks to my friend
from gloucester we had two i had two
different
amendments that were suggested for this
can be 14
one one was number four one four eight
six and one was one five o nine
to the extent that we can't reconsider
one 509
someone could offer 14
86.
point of order on that i'm sorry i'm
sorry but a point of order you're so
recognized
the clerk
thank you the clerk has
alerted
myself and i believe others that another
amendment is not cannot be offered at
this time
so
i hope that's a correct point of order
if
you're telling me that we can't the
committee cannot consider another
amendment
i'm just the messenger but that's what
i'm told
so then that's if that's the case then
there is no amendment we can rule on so
it's this ought to pass
without reconsideration that's the key
point but we've already done that and
that failed i believe 19 to 1.
representative espitio thank you mr
chair
i um
you know i appreciated your amendment
although i didn't support it um
i
as you know as the bell is stated i i
really
i thought it was much
worse without the amendment so i
actually
i'll be voting no on on this bill just
because i think there are changes that
need to be made to it and unfortunately
you know once again these exchanges are
not there
thank you and representative connolly
thank in respect to your point of view
which i should have ruled on already i
did not which was in and of itself it
should have been a point of order i did
receive a message from the
clerk that you are correct in order to
consider any other amendment
we would have to go back to the
reconsideration process and do all that
which
we know how that went
a point of order mr chairman
please state your point of order
i'm being told ought to pass is not a
valid motion at this point
the only thing that can
be done is a move to interim study or
reconsider the itl
or propose a new amendment that's what
i'm being told
can you reference any rule or anything
in any house rule or in the mason's
manual referencing that specific
conclusion that you reached
or anyhow
no the clerk
i asked that
representative burke
made a point of order i'm asking if you
can reference any house rule or anything
in the mason's manual suggesting that
we cannot consider an ot an
emotion about the past
i'm being told that it's already failed
so it cannot be brought back up
i would like you to call the clerk to
confirm that before we do this so that
you
i'm not going to rule uh i'm going to
rule that an automatic ought to pass
motion is proper
all about inquiry
you're not recognized for a
parliamentary degree
the motion right before the committee is
ought to pass well i'd like to speak on
that if you were in support of the
motion of ought to pass you're not going
to let me speak
representative you're speaking out of
order well everybody speaks on this
you don't want to go down this path i'm
telling you you're making a fool here
so stop you know let us talk
representative bert
the question is ought to pass
would you like to speak to that motion
about to pass yes please
okay you may speak to the motion ought
to pass on the underlying bill not any
amendment correct i don't want to talk
about any amendments
this bill has flaws in it and thank you
mr chairman this bill has flaws in it
and i think um
it's on line 25 or 26 where it should be
uh the law should be 6 30 colon 5 it is
6 30 colon 1 in here
there is other issues with this bill
you know and again i come back to bottom
line
they can hold these people that commit
these crimes today
you know let's stop this
you know six hours and 15-minute you
know work session
and i'm voting against this
i think a proper motion was the itl
and i am going to hopefully see that
today
and um so please vote against the it the
ought to pass motion
representative newman do you ever wish
to speak to the underlying bill
the question is off the passage i do
want to speak about the underlying bill
you're so regular
and my concern is that
i am concerned
trying to figure out how i'm going to
vote on this bill
um
is i don't understand what would happen
if we passed this
and the motion that we passed was
subsequently
found to not have been in order is
that's what confuses me and i'm just
going to have to wrestle with that
i'm just going to explain that nothing
to do with the underlying bill but
anyway at this point we'll now move the
question
the question is ought to pass if you're
in support of the motion of ought to
pass
please say
yay if you are opposed please say nay
the clerk will not call the role
vice chairman roy
yes
representative welch
representative burt
no
representative rhodes
yes representative greene
clark votes yes representative testament
yes representative genegan yes
representative pratt yes
representative marston
no
representative harriet gathright no
representative manjuputi
no
representative o'hearn
representative bordenay no
representative schultz
no
that was a no
representative newman
no
representative van
representative conley yes
representative bradley no
representative speak to you no
chairman abbas
the chair votes yes and representative
morrison was you
anyway nine yays 11 nays
i i dare even wonder what happens if an
emotion for interim study does not pass
welsh
well it's been finalized now
i attempted to do that
i asked the representative
can i pull everyone's vote if you were
i'm representing harry catherine i'm
allowed to pull the vote
that's it's a simple request
my understanding that it's been
finalized so
yes
mr chair point of information
so representative wells i'm not sure
what we're pulling at this point
[Applause]
i i thought the same works as well so at
this point
there's only one motion left to make
mr chair point of information
i'm going to recognize someone to make a
motion of in of interim city that's the
only available
or reconsideration point of information
since no other motion is on the floor
and
i just wanted i got the numbers of how
many people signed in for and against
online that's
we we don't need that now
i i think what we want to do is
tabling motion would not be a proper
motion
and i would say this i'm not going to
support an interim study
so but that's not just me but
representative speaker you wish to be
recognized for making it
this is back
representative speed did you wish to
make a motion to interim study yes i do
is that seconded by anybody
that was seconded by representative
harry gathered
representative welch
you can't vote till you have the audio
it's possessed okay
all right
mike's back
is and
representative speed did you wish to
speak to your motion to interim study
sure
um thank you mr chair
you know this is
the idea of what happened with fellow
reform and where we're at obviously
needs
needs some a lot of studying because it
just
the solutions for like we're not we're
just not coming up with the ones that we
can all agree on so i think we need to
clearly look more into the issue and
pull some actual data that's going to
help inform our decisions um
and hopefully we'll you know make sure
criminals are all not on the street but
we don't have you know that we also
don't have people locked away for
five to seven months for
waiting for a hearing so i will be
voting yes to the interim study
representative conley
yeah we've kind of exhausted our options
save for reconsideration
which still exists
so i'll be voting against interim study
with hopes of resurrecting this bill
thank you
representative
mr chairman who seconded it
oh welch okay thank you and um
so on the on the interim study i will be
supporting the interim study and i hope
um
you know everybody will follow so we can
go home before we have to order pizza
any any members wish to speak to haven't
spoken already seeing none at this time
we'll now move the question if you were
in support of the motion of interim
study
please say yes if you were opposed
please say no
where can i call the role vice chairman
roy no
representative welch
no
representative burt
yes
representative rhodes
representative greene
clerk votes no representative testament
[Music]
representative genegan
no
representative pratt no
representative marston
no
representative manjuputi
i'm i'm sorry
harry representative harriet catherine
yes
okay so that's true representative
manjuputi yes
representative o'hearn
no
representative bordenay
yes
representative schultz
no
representative newman
representative van
yes
representative connolly
no
representative bradley
yes
representative espitia yes chairman
abbas hey chair votes no
seven years 13 days interim study passes
fails excuse me
mr chairman mr chair
is it possible that we could
leave this for another time
and then go on with uh maybe one or two
other bills where we could actually do
something
we we have two other we have another
bill that we can we can hear today
actually
yes
all right five minutes
we we've been recess the committee will
be in recess for
until 4 30.
oh
the other day
okay
committee would now come to order we
will now reopen the executive session on
senate bill
and that the exec
this is this is the result it's going to
go to the house
or vote without recommendation
representative boardney would you
provide a
will you complete the representative
oh yes
i will and i'm right over here sure i'll
get a chance to read it
will anyone wish to make a
report
on supporting it not to pass
we'll discuss that later we have others
other business to take care of today as
well
you'll prepare a
report in support of ought to pass
there we have it
we now close the executive session on
senate bill 294
excuse me the executive session on 294.
306. yeah
thank you
and when will the blurb be required
at this time we'll now open the
executive session on senate bill
306.
does anyone wish to be recognized to
make a motion
represent a board name
thank you mr chair i'd like to make a
motion ought to pass
is there a second of the emotion about
to
pass it's been seconded by
representative welsh
representative boarding wished to speak
to your motion about to pass
yes chair um
i was a little uh hesitant on this bill
because i was unsure of what
uh
um crimes we were uh
talking about
updating to a penalty uh to
a felony
and i
was
shown that it is maybe subject to
enhanced policies which means that's the
jurisdiction that of the judge and that
makes me feel much more comfortable with
uh possible a felony being handed out to
someone
with this committed this crime
and just for clarification i think that
the
prosecutor has to notify the defendant
that they're going to seek the enhanced
penalties
that's that's my understanding the
procedure for that
it's and it's purely within the
discretion just there is a notification
period but it's not the judge per se
but it was clear from the uh
testimony of the uh
uh family who was here that uh
they did not feel like
the
the person who
caused the accident
received a harsh enough penalty
and
not enough to make them even hesitant to
do
texting again
so
i think
is a good idea i'll ought to pass
representative testament
i've had some
cases some
some reason to to be
with a friend of mine who was killed on
in that same area
uh
and dealt with the same
we they do the the family dealt with the
same
prosecutor in the same police department
and uh
it was only because his daughter
uh wouldn't let go
that they finally got some satisfaction
the guy got a year in jail
so i'm very sympathetic to them
uh
and but
you know it's
it's you know when it says may
the chances are
there's a good chance in amherst you're
not going to get it
representative burt
thank you mr chairman um
i'm voting uh against this bill and the
reason is
uh the state police said that there are
other laws that could have been used you
know like negligent driving and other
laws
um
you know i feel really sorry for the
family i do
i can't imagine
and you know the cost and just you know
working through that
the 60-day plea that that guy could have
got a year and i believe with other laws
that they could have filed
and they elected not to he could have
got more time
but he could have got at least a year
and he took a plea deal with the county
attorney i'm assuming and the judge had
to approve it i'm assuming um you know
for 60 days that's not
you know the fault of of you know trying
to enhance
penalties to felonies
you know i've always been very careful
and i've always been very nervous about
raising something
you know from a misdemeanor a b up to a
felony you know i want to make sure that
it's the right thing to do now you know
i believe in some cases it is
but i believe if i understood the
testimony correctly that there are laws
that they could have used and they
elected
not to
you know it's just rampant
people uh distracted driving and that's
the other thing too is i think that this
should have been
you know because i may have looked at it
a little different that if it was all
distracted driving because like i said
i've seen you know people reading a
newspaper going through the tolls as i
was coming up through and he he was
passing me
and the paper was in front of them and
i'm going holy crap
yeah i mean it's just
it's shocking to see people you know i
have a dash cam and some of the stuff i
pick up it's it's pretty remarkable that
you know we don't have 20 crashes a day
but there are laws that would have taken
this if the prosecutor wanted to go down
that path and for whatever reason he
didn't he gave the guy 60 days i
disagree with that he should have at
least got a year
you know so i i just can't in
conscience
vote for this
on the way it is thank you
and representative byrd i i agree that
you're what you're saying is correct in
the sense that other charges potentially
could have been brought there's
different elements that make negligent
operation
this so that would have to be proven so
for what this would do really if you
just it's a
distracted driving situation basically a
person was using their phone
while
while operating a motor vehicle and then
they caused a serious bodily injury it
would invoke the option of the enhanced
penalty
without having to go through the
difficult approving other offenses along
with
this one so there is a difference in
some sometimes if you miss one element
well not sometimes if you miss an
element on the charge it would all
you would lose it all and you would lose
the negative operation charge
so in that case if you're dealing with
someone simply who was using an
electronic device while operating
motor vehicle you wouldn't have to
improve anything other than they cause a
substantial bottle of
injury to
get the enhanced penalty so although we
agree that other things may perhaps
could have been done i'll be supporting
the ought to pass but i i do agree that
perhaps other things could have been
done but
yes
i appreciate that to allow me to respond
um
you know i agree with you um
you know but
somebody reading a newspaper or a woman
putting her eye makeup on or
i mean you know it's all distractive
driving it's all gonna you know could
hurt one of my grandkids or hurt my wife
or me and i mean or any of us you know
so i understand
why we need to do something here it's
just i i don't like the way this was and
and i'll be honest uh when the attorney
um
spoke
you know she really kind of turned me
away from the bill and and the reason is
because i
you know she said at first the gentleman
had no insurance
then she says well he had liability
insurance
and then there was a couple statements
that she made and that she corrected and
i'm going all right well you know
you know i don't think you know i don't
think she's telling us miss truth but it
was just
the way she spoke you know turned me off
on the bill um you know especially the
insurance pirate saying he had no
insurance or the individual she i don't
know if she said he or she um and that
um you know then that he had minimum
insurance
you know it's one or the other
you know so that was a red flag but then
when the officer or the uh state police
he said that there are other laws that
they could have used
um so i'm saying well why are we passing
something that they can do
so you know that's that's what it is
thank you for letting me speak again
representative wells
yes i'd like to take issue with
my colleague up here that just got
through speaking
because whether there was insurance or
not
the bodily injury that he
created
but whether he has an insurance or not
is immaterial he caused it
and he should
be punished and i think i'm going to
support this bill
at this time seeing no hands raised
when i moved the question if you are in
support of the motion of ought to pass
please say yes if you're opposed
uh please please say no the clerk will
not call the roll
vice chairman roy
yes
representative welch
representative burt
no
representative rhodes yes
representative green
clerk votes yes representative testament
yes representative genegan yes
representative pratt
yes
representative marston
representative harriet gathright
representative manjuputi
yes
representative o'hearn
no
representative bordenay
yes
representative schultz
no
representative newman
represent representative vann
yes
representative conley
representative bradley yes
representative espitia
um
yes
chairman abbas
chair votes yes 16 years
four nays one not voting
vote of 16
days
four nays the motion passes
will there be my minority report
not for me
representative bourne will you prepare
the majority report
thank you
this time we will now close the
executive session
on senate bill
306.
there was also a work session scheduled
today on
which
just
there was a there was a work session
scheduling another bill as well
i believe it was on
292.
there was no members of the there was no
there was no members of the public that
were going to
speak or offer any input on that so i
think if anything we can go into an
executive session on that we have two
bills left that need to we need to have
an executive session on
i would think we can get those done
today
and we we would that would include all
of our official business
i'll make the motion
at this time we'll open the executive
session on senate bill 292
relative to the penalty for
requiring notice of escape for
prohibition
excuse me
excuse me uh
thank you representative rose for
correcting that that is correct
yes
i wish to make a motion
292. i do apologize for being the
incorrect title representative roy you
recognize to make a motion
thank you i would move interim study
hear me out
second
i've seen it brought you so recognized
thank you
thank you mr chairman so i held a um
a call yesterday a
team's meeting call with
the major from the state police the
people from the parole probation board
from the
state it
uh that handles criminal record checks
and actually i was able to get all those
bodies to talk to each other and realize
that they can do this automatically
notification when someone is their
record is run in new hampshire
through the nic system sends an
automatic notification to whoever enters
the probation or parole record into the
next system
the problem that they were having is
that they had them they were all being
entered into a central office so one
office would get deluged with
notifications and then they had to track
down who that person
was being supervised for parole
operation and there was notification
wasn't happening so what parole
probation was trying to do is have that
notification done manually
well after the discussion we realize
that all they have to do
is each office has to enter their own
probation parole records that way the
notification comes right back to that
office
so an example is john doe gets arrested
his record is run he's being held
at the minute that record gets run as
part of the booking an automatic
notification from nix goes to the office
that supervises him for parole or
probation
so the very next morning when that
parole probation officer comes into work
they're notified that their person's
record has been run
and they can contact that office to find
out the status of that person so no
legislation is necessary
and this is again at the request of
parole and probation that we send this
during term study
and
no no law is necessary
there's very well said representative
rory
seeing no hands raised
see no hands raised oh representative
marston you're be recognized
thank you
i i guess i'm just interested in asking
a question of representative roy
in
the other piece of paper that we got
from
oxley the director of the field service
and so on and the department of
corrections
they were pushing to support this
so i'm wondering
why
and reading down through some of this
i'm seeing all kinds of
flags that say yes let's get this passed
so that
nobody can drop the ball
thank you for the question
representative marston they were
actually on the call with me yesterday
and after i was able to connect them
with the state police and the state i.t
people they realized they do not need
this legislation they are actually going
to handle it themselves within the
within the state framework that already
exists
they want this legislation because they
didn't know that they could do that and
now that they realize that that can be
done
um they no longer need this legislation
i will trust your word it and
representative martin marshes to
understand
this bill is very well intended because
of that notice needs to be transmitted
properly however the holding time period
i want to get into 72 hours of that time
period but that time period will not
start until the notice is given there is
no
solution if the notice is never given a
person's in
[Music]
kind of in a gray area where nowhere
land we'll call it so this
needed some work anyway
even if you were going to support
passing it
so
at this time representative harry
catherine thank you mr chair um
and actually we were waiting on data
because um
i know that's true too but i was just
remembered you guys saying that he would
make sure we got data on on this but
okay
thank you
on how long someone's generally held but
the 72 hours to not start until the
notice is provided what happens yeah
and and i made that clear to them that
that
that proposed extension did not have a
good future here so
so i'm sorry i was out of the room so
what is it it's a motion for interim
study
okay
representative newman
thank you i agree with everything that
representative roy said and additionally
just the manual process that's defined
in the bill has a lot of problems
especially if they forget to do it
and this time we'll now move the
question you should support the motion
of interim study
please say yes if you're opposed
please say no the clerk will now call
the role vice chairman roy yes
representative welch
yes representative burke yes
representative rhodes yes representative
greene clark votes yes representative
testament yes
representative genegan
yes
representative pratt
yes representative marston
with tongue-in-cheek yes
representative harry catherine yes
representative manager poody
yes representative o'hearn
representative bordenay yes
representative schultz
yes
representative newman yes representative
vann yes
representative conley
yes
representative bradley yes
representative espitia
it's gone okay
and chairman abbas
chair of what's yes
yay zero nays three not voting
represent royal prepare majority report
anyone move want to move for consent
so moved
this time we'll now close the executive
session on
senate bill 292
at
this time we'll now open the executive
session on senate bill 299.
that is relative to the penalty for
escape
could do some reconsiderations the
numbers look very different you want to
tell your friends to come back
didn't anyone wish to be recognized to
make a motion
and just
my understanding this in the committee
there was a lot of confusion on
what this bill would do
on how it would be applied
um
i lit i was actually not present in the
room i did listen to play back some of
the recording from that hearing just
my understanding is what this what
happened when they amended the law back
in
i want to say 2015 they made a change
they added the class a misdemeanor
section the problem is
that you have a class a section for a
class a felony you have a class b felony
section and a class a misdemeanor
section but as it's written you're
either going to be in a class
a felony or a class a misdemeanor
there's really no
mechanism
for it to fall into the class b
felony section
and this is designed to now allow
that opportunity i kind of looked at it
as like
think of like a piece of property that's
landlocked there's no
there's no way to get to it
so this would correct that problem
um representative roy you wish we
recognized to make a motion i do i wish
to move out to pass
is that seconded
that has been seconded by representative
rhodes representative already wished to
speak to your
your motion i do um
the necessity for for making this um
bill
part of what we heard at the testimony
um was
a problem with interstate as one of
several problems but one of them is
inter interstate pursuit or rendition of
an escaped prisoner
whereby escape would only be a
misdemeanor in new hampshire police are
first not allowed to pursue them across
state lines for misdemeanor second of
all with rendition
back to the back to new hampshire
many states will not hold or or someone
for rendition on a misdemeanor so once
they cut across state lines our escapees
for all intents and purposes were
were in many cases um scot-free
and and furthermore um the seriousness
of escape and now we're not talking
about just um this is from institutional
if i'm correct
is is not just um
it causes serious dangers for not only
that inmate other inmates and the guards
and police at large
it creates a credit incredible amount of
expense in in trying to recover that
inmate
and it creates a very dangerous
situation it shows a grave disrespect
for the rule of law for the judgment of
the court
and for the institution to which they've
been committed and frankly to their own
rehabilitation
so for those reasons i i support the
bill as proposed
uh representative harry catherine thank
you mr chair
i think um i made a couple notes here
because we talked about the young people
juvenile
we talked about there was no definition
for the terminology escape
um
i think it needs to be defined
so that we truly understand
what is an escape
so if let's say a young person decided
to
leave
um their
confinement area
and um
let's say go to the store or something i
don't know whatever
but with all intent to return but it's
during the time when they're not
supposed to is that considered an escape
first of all i will tell you the
looking for that the specific definition
for escape would ex that
problem would exist under existing law
or
whether whether senate bill
299 passes or not
the it's still gonna
the specific definition you're asking
about would still be a problem my
understanding is if you're in custody
and you
leave and no longer in the custody
without authorization that's that's an
escape
so if
if you leave the facility if you're in
the medical facility if you were to
do that that would be that would be an
escape
if you attempt to leave the medical
facility and are unsuccessful that's an
attempt to escape
but that's again that definition
it's
that's a problem under existing law as
well if that's your concern with the
bill representative portney
thank you chair
i i appreciate the uh intent of the bill
but
reading it it just is not clear what it
does
but i went back to the senate bill
before it was amended
that is much more clear i don't know why
the senate in their wisdom decided to
change the wording but
if you go back to the original senate
bill you'll find
it makes sense this is unclear
so i will be voting against the ought to
pass motion
representative rhodes thank you mr
chairman if i may just um
address the question that representative
gethrate had asked i remember
specifically
when
i i can't remember
the young lady's name was testifying and
she actually gave it different examples
and she did mention specifically that
you know in the event that a
a person was on like a work release
program but they were still technically
in the in the custody and you know
let's say there was some kind of a
traffic situation or you know something
that was making them not be back at the
time they were supposed to be that would
not be something they would consider to
to be an escape at all that they they
they do look at you know
extenuating circumstances if i may so if
i if i remember correctly she did
actually give give examples of exactly
what the definition of escape was
does that help
representative burt thank you mr
chairman um i'm going to be voting
against this bill and
let me explain why
when the prison uh you know she works at
the prison i can't remember her title
but you know she's pretty high up
she said in the last five years
30 people
in two this year
uh so last five years 30 people have
walked away
none were from behind the bars
one guy left a kitchen that he was
working for
walks down the road two hours later they
find him did no crimes
do i approve of him walking away no
but i also the years i've been on this
committee i understand that a lot of
these people
their education level
is is like a fifth grader you know it's
not very high
so all of a sudden you know we're going
to take this
fifth grader that is a full-grown person
and say okay well now you have a felony
you know it's just
you know i wish there was a mechanism
where they didn't have to you know
you know that it was optional which i
don't think it is i think if you walk
away
you know you're done uh she also said
that home confinement is also it's a
misdemeanor right now and
it will be a felony charge if that
person walks across the road
off the property
you know to see the neighbor or whatever
you know innocently they do this
now there was one person she said you
know from what i gathered the worst one
was the person went to virginia they did
rob a store
you know we need the discretion to grab
those people and and to punish them even
more
um
but to walk across the road
you know if the person that works in
that kitchen is is an uneducated person
you know he has a fifth grade or sixth
grade education he just walks down the
road um
you know you know i just can't
support a felony charge on those people
um there's got to be another way to um
try to do this and especially with the
such low numbers and and luckily there
was no you know major crimes uh you know
done by these people so
that makes me also feel that you know if
this bill failed you know maybe we could
bring back something that would address
the harsher
walk aways and not the smaller ones all
right thank you
i just want to clarify
this is
so if a classic it's a class a felony
for person employs force against another
person
right or they threaten that that person
with a deadly weapon to affect and
escape from custody so that we're
dealing with a violent situation that's
a class a
felony that
that's an existing law
now
we're talking about it's a class b
felony
this is existing law if someone were to
escape
from a juvenile facility
if it's a hospital but they're still you
know it's a med it's for medical
treatment they're there they're brought
by the
sheriff's department in those scenarios
the person's now escaped from custody
all right
that is
the way the law is written today is a
class b felony
uh the confusion that came up is whether
that escape involved the use of force or
not
so this is saying it's not
regardless if they used force
it's a class b felony that's someone
who's in custody who's escaping prison
that just is not exactly it's not using
a deadly weapon or using any type of
force to escape
they give in the movie if there's no no
violence in involved in the escape
that would be a class b felony
so
i think if you're in custody if you're
in prison
and you try to escape it should the very
least be a felony i'm i'm i don't i
don't see any reason why you wouldn't i
understand
if
there is a
section for a class a misdemeanor which
would
kind of opens the door for some some of
the items that weren't listed as a class
b felony so it's not listed as a class b
felony and doesn't involve
force or anyone no one got hurt then
it's a class a misdemeanor
so and if someone is prosecuted for that
it always could be
i'm not saying this would happen but it
could always as part of a plea could
always be played down to a class a
misdemeanor that's at least an option
i'm not saying that will happen i don't
that's a case-by-case basis
but
i i would be shocked that escaping from
a prison would be anything less than a
felony
that's just that's just my my take on it
so
representative roy
thank you i just wanted to address the
the question regarding the home
confinement and someone
innocently walking across the street to
talk to their neighbor
when
you're on a home good find generally
speaking you're on an ankle bracelet a
monitor
that gives you so many yards outside
your home and the the parole officer
shows you how far you can go
and when you leave that boundary it it
vibrates it beeps
and it sends an immediate notice to your
parole officer that you've gone outside
the boundary but it still shows them
where you are on a gps
now if you walk back across the street
after chatting with your neighbor after
15 minutes chances are you're going to
cut a call from your parole officer and
say what are you doing he's not going to
come scoop you up and try to violate you
and charge you with a felony
however if you cut that bracelet
you've now destroyed government property
as well as thumbs your nose at the court
and your parole officer and generally
all of society
keeping it a misdemeanor as i said has
consequences for rendition apprehension
and as far as i can research i i i can't
find any other state where escape from
prison is a misdemeanor there may be
some but i haven't been able to found it
yet
so if someone's in jail on a misdemeanor
now
we were going to charge him another
misdemeanor because they decided to
ignore that and walk away um i just it
doesn't make any sense
if you can't respect your opportunity
to be rehabilitated
and you're on a home confinement and not
behind bars i i can't see that as an
excuse to let you uh get out of jail
free card
so i will definitely be support
supporting this
see no hands raised at this time we can
now move the question if you in support
of the motion of ought to pass please
say yay if you're opposed please saying
no
the clerk will now call the roll vice
chairman roy
yes
representative welch
yes representative burt
no
representative rhodes yes representative
greene
clerk votes yes representative testament
yes
representative genegan yes
representative pratt yes representative
marston
yes
representative harriet gathright
um yes
representative manjuputi
yes representative o'hearn
representative bordenay
no
representative schultz yes
representative newman
yes
representative vann
representative conley
yes
representative bradley no
representative espitia
chairman abbas
that's here votes yes 15 years three
nays
what it was not finals she can get a
change of no problem so it's four genies
it's going to be four nays
emotion about to pass
this past will it be majority report
will it be a minority report
correct
this time we'll now close the
executive session on senate bill 299.
i believe that would conclude i think
we've now exact every bill that we have
this time the committee
committee will be adjourned
um
he said we had none left
did we do that could have reconsidered
bail
you